[Music]
thank you
hello everyone it's seven o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast thousands of
children with special educational needs
are missing out on their schooling as
Sky News reveals staggering delays in
the system this morning we'll bring you
the story of ten-year-old George
plus just how much are MPS making from
second jobs
we've got lots to come on a busy show
we'll be joined by the education
secretary Jillian Keegan and later we'll
hear from the head of the TUC Paul Novak
it's Friday the 14th of July
slipping through the cracks the children
with special educational needs missing
from classrooms because of delays in the
system
George has been let down not only by the
school but sometimes I feel like by me
because I'm his mum and I should
be able to give him really simple things
like an education
Sky News reveals the scale of the work
MPS are doing outside the day job and
who's making the most per hour
[Applause]
Hollywood brought to a standstill actors
join writers in their first strike for
more than 40 years
totally unacceptable calls for Urgent
reform as a report finds people forced
to pull out their own teeth because they
can't see a dentist
a common sweetener is classified as a
possible cancer risk by the World Health
Organization though experts say it's
safe in limited quantities
extreme heat continues to grip southern
Europe with warnings that temperature
records could be broken
[Music]
hello everybody good morning to you and
we start this morning with a special
report on the thousands of children with
special educational needs or
disabilities who are missing out on the
education they're entitled to because of
delays in the system designed to support
them well there are now half a million
children with what's called an education
Health and Care plan a legal document
that sets out extra support a child must
have the law is clear these plans must
be issued within 20 weeks but that
crucial deadline is missed in half of
all cases meaning thousands of children
are being forced to wait well Skies Nick
Martin speaks to one of the families
affected this is George's story
can you open up please
what's wrong George hasn't been to
school for the last six months his mum
at Rachel says he could no longer COPE
in a mainstream classroom because of his
complex learning difficulties he's 10
and he can't read or write
this is naming which sounds
the living room is now a classroom and
Rachel who has no teacher training
whatsoever has had to quit her job to
teach her son I'm actually really sad I
think that George has been let down not
only by the school but sometimes I feel
like by me because I'm his mum and I
should
be able to give him really simple things
like an education
and I am struggling to do that what is
this there's a sign here like half a
million other children in England George
has an education Health and Care plan
outlining extra support for special
educational needs and disabilities or
scnd for short by law George's local
Council must provide him with an
education but so far they haven't found
him any alternative provision yet
everything on his educational healthcare
plan should be provided
that's the whole point it's a legal
document saying that George needs this
and this and this and this why on Earth
is it not happening I can't answer that
I don't know Georgia school told us they
worked with the local Council and had
successfully obtained Georgia's
Education Health and Care plan they said
education is available both in school
and remotely but they added at the time
of writing no additional scnd funding
has been received we asked Essex County
Council why they haven't found George
any alternative provision they said it
would be inappropriate to comment on
individual cases adding any concerns
raised by parents or dealt with
according to our established processes
and we are in touch with the family
directly
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
has announced a special educational
needs Improvement plan but it won't roll
out until after the next election it's
unlikely to help children like George
who are more likely to be absent and who
struggle to get into a special school
due to a shortage of places in 13 years
of government we've known that there has
been pressure in Sen
this lad's 10 years old he could have
been helped if you'd done the
improvements earlier
and now he's not getting an education he
didn't have you not accept that he has
been let down we did not have the
volumes I'm just I just want to be clear
do you accept that this young line has
been like I I see people like George in
my surgeries a lot and I spend all my
time fighting for a place in one of our
local schools because I you know I can
see that there's there's three and a
half times over subscribed but the
amount of people needing support as as
definitely grown faster than the
capacity do not accept just naturally
accept the fact that this lad is not
going to be helped by your no you will
you will be helpful he won't be helped
as much as we want to as quickly as we
want to sit down ready sit down there
are thousands of George's thousands of
us that need more help
and we need something to be done
George's education is on hold and as
each day passes he slips further behind
Nick Martin Sky News
well he saw the education secretary
Jillian Keegan in that report well
she'll be live on the sofa at around 20
past seven so do you join us for that
now for the latest in our Westminster
accounts series looking at how money
moves through Westminster analysis by
Sky News shows which MPS are spending
the most time working outside Parliament
and how much they make we can reveal the
average hourly pay for an MP's second
job is more than 17 times the national
average and two former Prime Ministers
topped the list here's our Deputy
political editor Sam coats
what should politicians do with their
time
ban all second jobs for MPS I don't have
any objection
um to MPS having a an insight into the
outside world second jobs divide MPS and
often anger their voters you get paid
best part of 90 grand a year should be
enough we've voted them in to run this
country so that's what they should do
Sky News is Westminster accounts project
has followed the money through our
political system now we reveal the scale
of MP's commitment to their second jobs
for the first time we can show you the
total of how much time MPS say they
spend on their outside work nearly 89
000 hours that's the total amount of
time all MPS have worked in second jobs
over the course of this Parliament so
three and a half years let's see how it
all breaks down these are the MPS who
commit the most hours to their second
jobs
there's some names in there you might
recognize Sir Jeffrey Cox they've become
notorious for their commitment to
outside work but most have one thing in
common all the names on this list have
second jobs in politics councilors
Mayors members of the Scottish
Parliament double political job in
keeping them very busy
and something else we can show you for
the very first time this is the average
hourly wage of an MP in a second job
233 pounds per hour
how does that compare to the rest of the
population well it's a lot higher the
average hourly wage for an MP in a
second job is over 17 times the average
rate for a member of the UK public and
more than 22 times the minimum hourly
wage
which MPS are getting the most cash for
the hours they work this leaderboard
shows you that these 20 MPS have the
highest hourly rates in Parliament the
name of the top is no surprise Boris
Johnson now free to spend even more time
earning big bucks away from Westminster
the second name on this list is the
shortest live PM in British history but
that has hardly dented her earnings
power Liz truss her most lucrative work
since leaving number 10 has been a
speech in Taiwan paid at a rate of 20
000 pounds an hour nearly one and a half
thousand times the UK average hourly
wage for her insights into Global
diplomacy and that's part of a very
common pattern MPS who've served in
government dominate this leaderboard 18
of the MPS with the highest hourly
earnings this Parliament have government
experience clearly a very lucrative
addition to any parliamentarian CV
plans for major second job reforms have
Frozen in this Parliament is it just a
matter of time until voters force a
change Samco Sky News
well in the next hour Hollywood's film
and TV industry will effectively shut
down with actors joining writers in and
on in going on strike it follows a
collapse in talks with Studios and
streaming companies over paid conditions
and concerns over the use of artificial
intelligence Martha Kellner has the
latest
this is the first time in 63 years that
both the writers and the actors in
Hollywood have been on strike at the
same time and it is relatively Uncharted
Territory I was down at a picket line
with writers who have been on strike now
for two months and a huge cheer erupted
as they learned the news that the actors
who bring their words to life would be
joining them on strike because they know
that this makes their bargaining
position with the Production Studios and
the streaming Giants all that much
stronger we've already seen this taking
effect it's not just the film and TV
production that stops almost immediately
it's the bells and whistles around this
industry the things like the premieres
the the pressed on kits the photo shoots
Oppenheimer Premiere in London the Stars
had already walked the red carpet when
they got news that this strike was
happening the likes of Emily Blunt and
Killian Murphy walked away from that
event straight away it's clear that many
many actors are very committed to this
cause and in fact I've barely had a
whisper from anyone within the acting
Community who doesn't think that this is
the right course of action and this
campaign has been led by the likes of
Jennifer Lawrence Meryl Streep Mark
Ruffalo they were all signatories to a
letter urging their Union to take a hard
line and this is where We've Ended up
with a dual strike for actors and
writers
people are being forced to pull up their
own teeth at home because they can't
afford or access an NHS dentist that's
according to a new Rapport by the health
select committee which found DIY
extractions have been performed with
pliers in some cases While others have
been forced to make a five hour round
trip to see a professional the committee
recommends updating current contracts
with dentists and launching a public
information campaign to explain how NHS
Dentistry works
and coming after course away we're going
to be speaking to the head of the MP
group behind that report Steve brine
let's take a look at some of the day's
other headlines now and the World Health
Organization has formally classified a
common artificial sweetener as a
possible carcinogen but won't change its
Health guidance Aspartame is used in
thousands of products including diet
soft drinks ice cream and chewing gum
and the health bodies report says while
there may be a potential cancer risk the
sweetener is safe in limited quantities
the funeral of one of the victims of
last month's attacks in Nottingham is
taking place today 19 year old Barnaby
Weber was walking home from a night out
with fellow student Grace O'Malley Kumar
when they were stabbed to death a 31
year old man has been charged with their
murders and will face trial in January
Hollywood actor Kevin Spacey will be
cross-examined in his sexual assault
trial the Oscar winner has started
giving evidence to the court claiming he
was flirtatious and romantic with one of
his alleged victims he's previously
denied all 12 charges against him
relating to four men between 2001 and
2013.
Health authorities in the U.S have
approved a birth control pill for sale
without a prescription for the first
time ever Opel also labeled the mini
pill contains just one hormone and has
been used under prescription since 1973.
a brawl erupted in kosovo's Parliament
after an opposition politician threw
water on the Prime Minister it came
after a tense three-day debate about
unrest in the north of Kosovo Alban
curti was speaking about the government
measures to diffuse tensions between
ethnic serbs when emotions spilled over
now Hollywood may be on strike but today
junior doctors in England are preparing
to strike for a second day too the
government said there'll be no more
negotiations after offering a six
percent salary rise in line with
independent pay review bodies but the
BMA wants 35 percent the government's
offer does now mean that millions of
other UK public sector workers will get
a pay rise the police in England and
Wales will get a seven percent pay rise
and the same goes for prison officers
and the armed forces are to get five
percent as well as an additional one
thousand pounds Consolidated increase
NHS Consultants specialist doctors
salaried dentists and GPS in England
will get six percent and the same as
Junior doctors as well as a one-off
increase of 1250 pounds and teachers in
England will be given a six and a half
percent pay rise teaching unions have
now suspended all their planned strikes
and will be speaking to the head of the
trades Union Congress Paul Novak at
around half past seven to get his
reaction to those pay Rises
in the meantime countries in southern
Europe are preparing emergency measures
as a heat wave has gripped the region
and it's expected to break record
temperatures in Greece the government
has ordered work to stop between 12 and
5 in the afternoon in areas where the
risk from heat is very high so let's get
more on this our energy and climate
change correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
is in the Greek city of Perez for us now
so Hannah high temperatures expected
there and the government recommending
people don't go out in certain hours
yeah because a public health emergency
in some instances even in a place like
Athens which is a well used to the Heat
this is the port area just outside the
city where we've been speaking to
Holiday makers going off to the islands
and a lot of them have said that they
are being extra cautious they are
heeding the warnings a number of Greek
families have said that they're a little
bit baffled about all the fuss they say
that greet is a very hot place and it's
a society that's already orientated
around taking care of themselves during
the hottest hours but the Greek
authorities are taking no chances
there's been a public health campaign
they're asking people to stay indoors
most public buildings are shut today and
they are saying no food deliveries for
example between 12 and 5 as the heat
builds it's possibly going up to 40
degrees today and it might get even
hotter tomorrow but when you look at the
forecast actually these very high
temperatures high 30s are going to
extend for another 10 days or so so very
little relief for people in Greece and
it's a similar picture across southern
Europe this area of pressure trapped
over North Africa Spain Portugal but
even into Bulgaria and Kosovo and we've
seen the impact of that already not just
in public health but in wildfires that
have been sparked in Croatia tourists
and residents alike evacuated that
beyond the immediate impact the
emergency issues there's another thought
as well here and that's about the
economic impact on people in terms of
livability in terms of their abilities
to do their job and their ability to be
productive members of society when it is
this hot for this long those things
start to deteriorate and that's a big
problem for governments they try to
Grapple with this new reality driven by
climate change
Hannah thanks very much indeed
well with parts of the world
experiencing extreme weather conditions
let's take a look at the impact of
climate change on the planet and there's
our data dashboard you can see the right
hand side of the screen shows how the
UK's power is currently being produced
and meanwhile on the top left you can
see how much warmer the Earth is now
than when records began in 1880 around
the time the Industrial Revolution you
can see it's added
1.27 degrees and finally bottom left is
the total amount of carbon dioxide
emissions in millions of tons and you
can see all those figures are ticking up
even as we watch them
so we're going to get more now on the
pay review announcement Yesterday by the
government prime minister yesterday
announced that he would follow the pay
review bodies recommendations on pay so
let's get some reaction to that I'm
joined now by the education secretary
Jillian Keegan welcome to you thanks so
much
um so teachers are being offered a six
and a half percent pay increase the
teaching unions have come on board say
they're happy with that and they'll
recommend it to their members but how
confident are you that teachers will
accept that given that it's still below
inflation which is 8.7 percent
um I mean it's the unions really that
have got the best judgment on that and
and they they seem to be uh confident uh
that their members will do that but of
course it will have to go to the ballot
I do have um um a couple of cousins who
are teachers who've been kind of keeping
me in contact and uh they all got in
touch yesterday and were delighted
actually with the news so
um I'm hoping that they're indicative of
the rest of the profession I mean you
know teachers do an amazing job they
don't want to strike they want to be in
the classroom with children they know
that children need to catch up they know
there's lots of things that they you
know they're absolutely vital
um uh you know to our children so they
do an amazing job they want to be there
and and I know they didn't want to
strike actually as well so I think
hopefully with the unions recommending
it um they will be back in the classroom
so they're getting six and a half
percent pay rise it's more than had
originally been expected which may be
good news for teachers but there's more
money to find isn't there so our
school's gonna have to find that money
from within their budgets or are you at
the Department of Education giving them
all that extra money so what's always
difficult about this is not the headline
figure but how it's funded and if for
example you said well you know this is
the percentage but you have to fund it
out of your own budgets then schools
just simply couldn't expect it because
it couldn't accept it because what that
would mean is a head teacher would have
to make a decision between you know
giving somebody a pay rise and maybe
making somebody redundant or canceling a
program or something like that and it
will just be
um you know really difficult for them to
do that so one of the things that's made
this really difficult is I've known all
along that whatever we offer we also
have to offer to fund not all of it
because there is some within the school
budgets that they were expecting and
they budgeted for but quite a big chunk
of it so in this case we've had to find
uh you know a significant amount of
money which we the department will have
to um you know send to schools to to
make it affordable so how have you found
that money where's it come from from
within the department so what usually
happens in in budgets Within in the
Departments we have quite a big
education budget we do spend a lot of
money on education what usually happens
is you have programs which you estimate
either the demand LED forecast or how
how quickly you're going to deliver them
and what happens in in government
budgeting is if you don't spend it all
and very often you don't spend it all
because you overestimate how quickly you
can roll things out Etc then all that
money usually goes back to the treasury
and what's happened in in this case and
the treasury of work with us to enable
us to do that is they've given us the
flexibility to take those anticipated
underspends and to move them into
Teachers Pay so basically we've gone
through every single line every single
budget painstakingly I mean I've worked
in business for 30 years I've done this
a lot and we've gone through and we've
anticipated where we will not um you
know we wouldn't meet the forecast and
we will move that into uh into school
funding okay so if it's come from an
underspend that's okay for this year but
but what about
for future years as well we've looked at
Future years so we've looked at this
year and and uh next year which are the
two years that are left within the
spending review and then of course it
gets Consolidated into the spending
review and that's what happens every
year with everything actually you know
everything that we have which is a real
reoccurring cost every spending review
of course that's uh looked at and you
say that's where most of the money will
come from but schools will have to make
some adjustments themselves no we have
schools have budgeted so what you look
at in school budgets is of course they
have anticipated
um that they would have um you know some
pay Rises so they all um and this was
actually the problem when I very first
arrived in the department they'd all put
three percent in the budget and the
independent pay review body came back
with 5.4 that was last year that's the
extra two billion pounds that I had to
get when I very first started the job
now they've put three and a half percent
in and the independent pay review body
has come back with six and a half so
it's they have some which they have
within their budgets there's something
else we've done as well because I always
look at school budgets across the
average but of course there could be
some schools like maybe a smaller school
that's got specific concerns so we've
also we've got a school a school support
fund as well and we've increased that by
40 million pounds so that if there's a
school that's in exceptional
circumstances then we've increased the
money that that they can come and access
okay so teaching unions have accepted
the deal Junior doctors don't seem so
happy they've been offered a six percent
the British Medical Association was
saying yesterday that it amounts to yet
another cut in uh pay cut in real terms
Junior doctors ongoing strikes at the
moment Consultants due to go on strike
next week where is this all going to end
when the Prime Minister says there'll be
no more tall well we can all see
inflation no the junior doctors are not
unusual we have all got the impacts of
inflation and our household budgets and
you know every single person actually
across the world not even just across
this country has seen the impacts of
inflation and that is why we are very
focused on halving inflation you can't
Chase inflation you need to get rid of
inflation so they are not exceptional in
in having you know inflationary
pressures we all have inflationary
pressures everybody does but what we
have to do is halve inflation and we
have to make sure and it's been really
quite quite difficult to do during these
um you know these times to to agree a
pay
um you know a pay increase without
um you know having adding to inflation
so the government was suggesting that
any pay Rises over five percent would
add to inflationary pressure some of the
pay Rises going up to seven percent so
the government changes no it's been very
difficult to try and navigate this and
what what basically has been key is not
um not having any new borrowing and not
raising new taxes which could fuel
inflation it is a tricky Balancing Act I
mean there's no doubt that has made this
thing you know trying to be fair trying
to um you know give public sector pay
workers pay Rises but also trying to
make sure that we have
um you know inflation this is not easy
it's moving around and there's lots of
driving factors underneath that are
moving around it has made it more
difficult but I would urge the BMA you
know the independent pay review bodies
have done a very thorough analysis and
they look at you know rates of
recruitment retention they look at all
the other sort of professions or similar
professions so they do do a very
thorough job and so you know I think
it's uh I think it's only fair that they
should look at that and take that
seriously okay we've been reporting
today on why so many children with
special educational needs and
disabilities are waiting so long
um for education and health care plans
they're deemed absolutely critical but
councils are only managing to issue half
of them within the 20-week time limit
it's a failing system isn't it I mean do
you accept that the government
underestimated the spike in in demand
and is failing the system the system is
under a lot of pressure and and the core
reason it's under a lot of pressure is
the massive increase in demand I mean
our special educational needs budget in
the last four years has doubled is now
over 10 billion pounds so it is under a
lot of pressure that's why we put
forward our special educational needs
Improvement plan which does a number of
things it invests in more school places
invest in more educational psychologists
more senkos so there is a Workforce plan
that goes with that as well but there's
no doubt there's a massive increase in
demand and we know a lot more about
special educational needs you know we
know a lot more about how to diagnose
various special educational needs what
we can do to help children overcome them
if they're not getting those it has put
pressure on the system and it is you
know we are we are training more
educational psychologists for example
that's one of the key skills that you
need but also five thousand more senkos
we have recognized that you know a
doubling in in four years is very
difficult for any system to keep up with
um but you know we do you know special
educational needs in this country we
take extremely seriously we have an
excellent system really but it isn't
keeping up with demand that's why we
have the send Improvement plan it's why
we're putting more money into into
places and into supporting uh councils
as well okay just just finally I do want
to ask you um we are putting out today
the latest in our Westminster accounts
reports and in that we've revealed that
MPS with second jobs have an average
wage of 233 pounds per hour that's 17
times at the national average
um it's all permitted all within the
rules but do you think those rules are
right given that teachers for example
they can't top up their pay are you
comfortable about the rules as they
stand now well actually teachers can top
up their pay with the national tutoring
scheme and they've been doing an
excellent job of helping children catch
up as well but um I mean I would imagine
that those figures are probably just a
small number of people who you know you
hear about these people you know get
lots of money for speaking engagement
it's an average wage well but the
average will be I mean I I haven't
contributed a single penny to that
average I know that I mean obviously I
have two jobs with the ministerial role
as well but the the reality is that's
probably a small number of people who
are doing you know speeches on the
speaker's circuit who are getting paid
an awful lot
um and yes this is permitted and they
have to go through all the rules in
Parliament and it's something that's
permitted but uh I know that I'm not
contributing to that average okay well
Jillian Keegan we appreciate your time
this morning thanks very much indeed
thank you very much
let's take a look at what the weather's
up to now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well there's a heat wave for southern
Europe but the rather cool and unsettled
conditions here will continue
unseasonably strong winds in the south
over the next few days may bring some
disruption and it's a mainly dry start
in the north but Wind and Rain are
taking over more of the South the rest
of Southern Britain Ireland and Northern
Ireland will see rain through the
morning heavier times further north
expect brighter more showery conditions
and it'll be rather cool and windy with
the strongest winds in the southwest
where Coastal Gales are possible much of
Northern Britain will turn wet though
during the afternoon
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming next on Sky News break first
millions of public sector workers are
offered pay Rises but is it enough to
stop all of the strikes the General
Secretary of the trades Union Congress
Paul Novak joins us in a moment
foreign
[Music]
you're watching Sky News breakfast a
reminder of our top stories here this
morning and thousands of children with
special educational needs or
disabilities are missing out on
schooling because of delays in councils
issuing Education Health and Care plans
at Sky News Westminster accounts
investigation has found MPS with second
jobs earn an average wage of 233 pounds
per hour that's more than 22 times
higher than the minimum hourly wage
and in Hollywood actors will be joining
screenwriters in strikes due to start
within the next hour which threatened to
bring the film and TV Industries to a
halt
that's great
so the government has accepted the
recommendations of the pay review body
so millions of UK public sector workers
will now get a pay rise Junior doctors
though insist it's not enough and
they're going to walk out again today so
our political correspondent as you can
see Robert Is Here morning to you and so
we just spoke to the education secretary
she feels very confident because the 14
main education unions have come on board
with their offer of six and a half
percent and are going to recommend it to
their members but I guess the members do
now have to vote yeah I think this was a
bit of a Victory lap for the education
secretary um this morning because I I
think out of all of what happened
yesterday it's probably the best result
in terms of getting unions the teaching
unions to suspend their strikes of
course it's now up to members to decide
she said that the message she was
getting from unions was that they were
confident that members would back this
of course if we think back to the
nursing Union dispute the the head of
the Royal College of Nursing was backing
the offer they were given but their
members went the other way so it could
be a bit of a hostage Fortune saying
that they're confident they'll come on
board but let's see
um I think as well on that crucial
question of where this money is actually
coming from we got a bit more clarity as
well because schools had already been
given money to a sort of budget for
about three and a half four percent pay
Rises clearly what they're getting now
is six and a half percent so they will
be getting extra money coming from the
Department for education so they don't
have to cut back on other things but
where's the DFE the department finding
that from well Jillian Keegan say that
says that that will come from areas
where they're not spending quite as much
as they thought they would areas where
they're maybe doing things a little bit
more efficiently
um or quickly and money that would
usually go back to the treasury is now
going to stay in the department to pay
for this so that is sort of being
presented as a win as almost new money
that would have had to go back to the
treasury that is staying in the
department now and Julian Keegan
crucially said that that has been
accounted for this year and next year as
well because of course these pay Rises
are Consolidated so they'll have to find
it next year too before it goes into the
spending review and overall departmental
spending is looked at so I think for for
teachers and for the education secretary
a win clearly when it comes to Junior
doctors the picture is very different
though where it looks to really be in
complete standoff stalemate the Prime
Minister saying no more talks the BMA
saying Junior doctors in England simply
need more than the six percent plus a
bonus payment that they are being given
they have some leverage of course given
Rishi sunak desperately wants to try and
get waiting this down but I think the
end result is we're staring down the
barrel of potentially rolling strikes
going on for months and maybe the rest
of this year yeah quite a stalemate
there isn't there and Rob thanks very
much indeed well let's talk about that
and these issues a little bit further
because I'm joined Now by The General
Secretary of the trades Union Congress
Paul Novak a very good morning to you
Paul Novak and first of all do you
welcome the fact that the government's
decided to back these independent pay
review bodies when it comes to public
sector pay do welcome that well I think
it looks different in different sectors
Anna so if you look at education uh I
think it is right that the Prime
Minister accepted the findings of the
pay review body six and a half percent
is the largest award that body has ever
recommended but crucially the Prime
Minister has also said and Jillian
Keegan's just confirmed it on your
program that this will be fully funded
for schools and I think it's on that
basis that our teaching and head
teaching unions have said that we'll
take this to our members obviously
members will be the ones that ultimately
decide but I think that is a positive
step forward I think in other parts of
the public sector there's much less
clarity about where the money for these
pay Rises uh will come from and I know
for example uh in health the the
hospital consultants and Specialists
Association at TUC at Union is concerned
about you know effectively the salami
slicing of NHS funding Robin Peter to
pay Paul to fund any pay rise and so
they're still calling on the government
to sit around and negotiate so I think
it looks very different in different
parts of the public sector but I think
overall uh I would say that the Prime
Minister and him accepting those pay
review body Awards wouldn't have
happened if union members hadn't stood
up uh taking that really difficult
decision to vote for strike action and
show the government that they were
prepared to accept getting other uh
real-time papers
you say that Health unions still aren't
happy they still want more talks but the
Prime Minister made it absolutely clear
yesterday that there would be no more
negotiations and no amount of strike
action would change his decision so
where does that leave things we just got
a months of strikes ahead well I think
it would be uh really remissible
government to ignore the concerns of NHS
staff and indeed other public sector
staff people need to know where these
pay Rises whether these pay Rises will
be funded because what they don't want
to do is see the services that they're
very proud to deliver they're committed
to delivering being subject to cuts um
there are other issues uh to be honest
with you and in the prison Service uh
for example I know that our prison
Officers Association is concerned that
experienced staff won't get any increase
at all uh because uh the the pay rise is
contingent on their move into a new pay
scale again I think these are the sort
of issues that the government needs to
sort of clarify and talk to unions about
remember prison officers by law aren't
allowed to strike so I think that puts a
special responsibility on the government
to talk seriously to our prison Officers
Association
as far as doctors are concerned they're
being offered a six percent pay rise the
BMA wants them to get 35 do you think
those demands are reasonable
well the BMA isn't a TUC Affiliated
Union and I don't want to speak on their
behalf but I think they've been very
clear all along that what they want to
see is a pathway to pay restoration
that's really important that we're going
to solve the Recruitment and Retention
crisis in our NHS now I don't think the
BMA or the htsa believe the government
is going to put 35 on the table this
year I think what they want for the
government is to set out how they are
going to restore pay and how they are
going to stop solve the uh the
recruitment to retention crisis for for
junior doctors and indeed for more
senior staff in the NHS so you know I
think this is a little bit of a red
herring no employer goes into a
negotiation and says to a union oh your
first offer is that that's the only
basis on which you're having a
discussion that's not the way that
industrial relations work and I think
really deep down uh the government knows
that
but but do you think the BMA shouldn't
have gone with this 35 figure what's
your I know they're not part of the TUC
but what's your personal view well as I
say I wouldn't cut across another
Union's negotiating position and and at
the end of the day the decisions about
you know what claim goes in what
industrial action has taken is taken by
BMA members unlikely so it's not taken
by me or indeed just the leaders of the
BMA it's taken by by members and I
respect their decision
um let's talk a little bit more about
the funding because the government has
said that it won't borrow anymore and
they and it won't raise taxes they want
to be fair to the taxpayer they're
mindful of inflation and the general
economic picture they say that
departments will have to re-prioritize
and make efficiencies what do you think
that means and what effect do you think
it'll have
well as I say in education the
government has been clear that they will
fully fund schools for this pay pay
award and I think that's that's right I
do have broader concerns about the
public sector of other governments as I
said before Robin Peter to PayPal and
this is where I fundamentally disagree
with the governments I think we do have
to have a national debate about taxation
not to put taxes up for Supermarket
workers or School teachers or people
working in factories but you know not
everybody's been living through a cost
of living crisis uh dividends have risen
three times faster than wages we've seen
an explosion uh in Chief Executives pay
and I think that those with the broader
shoulders could be asked to pay more so
the TUC for example we've called for
capital gains tax to be equalizer with
income tax and Keen to explore issues
around things like a wealth tax uh there
isn't a fixed pot and money there and at
the end of the day if we want decent
Public Services if you want to pay the
people who deliver those Services uh at
a fair wage then you have to think about
those with the broader shoulders paying
their fair share
the offers yesterday range from kind of
around five percent to seven percent
increases for public sector workers it's
it's more than a lot of people have
expected it's more perhaps than the
government originally had hoped to spend
so do you think this should be the
backdrop
to an end of strikes that's been so
persistent around the country this year
no as I say I think in education and
ultimately these decisions will be taken
by members Anna our unions are
recommended the members that accept that
that award but you know at the end of
the day across the public and private
sector workers are still facing another
real terms people we've got a government
that's got no long-term plan for
boosting wages and instead it actually
is intent on attacking trade unions who
will stand up for people to get decent
wage risers I mean the high court
overturned uh the government's attempt
to allow employers to exploit agency
workers to undermine strike action
um that was just yesterday the high
court declared the government's actions
unlawful and irrational they're driving
through their anti-strikes legislation
now that will take away one in five
workers right uh to strike I want a
government that's a series about
engaging with unions serious about
listening to public and private sector
workers rather than attacking trade
unions
okay well Paul Novak we really
appreciate your time General Secretary
of the TUC thanks very much indeed for
your views thank you
now then it's when semi-finals stay at
Wimbledon one of the grass courts that
got in store for us Jackie valtraut is
there for us so another exciting day at
Wimbledon Jackie what do you reckon
well I think uh you would be a fool to
think that Novak Djokovic isn't going to
come out of his semi-final with a
Yannick sinner today I mean what do we
know about Yannick sinner he he's very
young he's Italian he's uh 21 very very
tall and thin could have been a
fantastic skier for Italy and he has
some great fancy following rounds called
the uh the Los carotas the karate boys
who dresses carrots uh because he's got
Ginger hair and follow follow him around
and cheer him on so they'll probably be
there today on Center Court but he's got
a very tough task against Novak Djokovic
who is going for his eighth Wimbledon
title which is the same number as Roger
Federer who thought that record would
ever be matched but he could do it this
Wimbledon five in a row incredible and
the other semi Carlos alcaraz the world
number one the 20 year old from Spain
who plays such flamboyant tennis really
aggressive tennis is an absolute well it
blows your mind how well he plays all of
the time especially on the surface is
playing Daniel Medvedev from Russia who
missed last year because of the ban and
his backs this year making the most of
his appearance at Wimbledon you'd have
thought alcaraz would have too much for
him the match in the final that
everybody wants to see is a repeat of
the French Open final alkaraz against
Djokovic Djokovic super confident as you
can imagine
I don't want to sound arrogant but of
course I don't consider myself favorite
you know
you know judging with for the the
results that I had in the in my career
here and in previous
four
occasions of Wimbledon that I won you
know and reaching another semi-final so
I do consider myself favorite yes
so that's the men's semi
the women's final
row we'll get we'll get a brand new
Champion tunisia's algebra full of
smiles yesterday producing a superb
comeback in her semi-final to beat the
second seed Arena zavalenka Shabba came
from a set in a breakdown to reach a
second successive Wimbledon final she
really was on the cusp of going out and
turned it round
[Applause]
the first unseated player to reach the
women's singles final in the open era
perhaps the one with the most tattoos as
well the check player they're very
popular Ukrainian Elena spitalina in
straight sets and she has beaten algebra
twice this year so that is going to be a
very tough one to her
[Applause]
so that's Wimbledon in a nutshell let's
have a look at the rest of the sport
the Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
Wimbledon in full bloom one of the most
glorious scenes in all of Sport the it's
a place this man has got to know well
Kam Nori cycled to the Championships and
all the way to the last four last year
so how much does he feel sustainability
time to find out here he is
are you Cam how are you doing very well
thank you good to see you nice to see
you what is it like to be back here
can't complain so nice especially when
the weather's like this yeah so do you
fancy having a little Wanderer around
reliving some memories chat a bit of
climate let's do it let's do it
foreign
[Music]
Court 16. talk to me yeah I remember she
was my first ever main draw men's win
here so very special court for me what
did that feel like
the major moment for you I think it was
one of those days I was so nervous for
the match so tight because I'd never
want to match here
um and I just really wanted to get over
the line so I think it was more of a
relief more than like enjoying it so
what about climate and climate change
when did you first sort of have exposure
to this topic I guess yeah actually I
remember taking a sustainability class
at TCU where I went to University in the
states and one of the things that stood
up for me was I don't know why but it
was in the Netherlands how many people
biked to work there and I was thinking
like for me why can't I do the same and
and around London when I'm I'm here I'm
biking to practice and definitely it's a
good warm-up good cool down and yeah
growing up in New Zealand everyone's
pretty conscious of of everything
they're protecting the beaches and and
my parents and the way I was raised so I
was I was always kind of thinking of it
and then with the adding it into
University and learning a little bit
more I became a bit more interested in
it
foreign
Sports bulletin is brought to you by
vitality
okay thanks very much indeed do so with
us still to come here on Sky News
breakfast as a new report reveals some
people have been forced to pull their
own teeth out because they can't access
or afford an NHS dentist or speak to
health select committee chair Steve Ryan
[Music]
a lot of action going on I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
makes
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I'm Stuart Ramsey and I'm Sky's Chief
correspondent well there's a real sense
now that people are beginning to expect
that this whole airlift is coming to an
end and they're really really desperate
that's what's going in grabbing people
and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
Venezuela is eager for change with them
crust
we'll take you to the heart of stories
that shape our world they were convinced
the United States would become hooked
we're all right
the normal six version the sits come
down it was just landed in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire net
Syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
so so hot
[Music]
thank you
let's get more now on calls for Urgent
reform of NHS Dentistry after a report
by the Health and Social care committee
found people are pulling out their own
teeth because they can't access or
afford an NHS dentist or the committee
is a chair Steve brine joins us now very
good morning to you Steve Bryan thanks
so much for talking to us
tell us first of all about what you
found during this report what kind of
steps are people resorting to when they
can't get affordable treatment
well it's not pretty
um you know we did a lot of work on this
we had a huge interest in this inquiry
you know round tables
um a huge amount of evidence that came
into us you know we found people who
couldn't get access
um you know couldn't afford private
treatment pulling teeth out themselves a
five hour round trip for children
um we heard four and a half year old who
hadn't seen a dentist since he was a
baby
um despite I think his parents said
they'd tried 10 practices to try and get
NHS treatment and you know yeah
obviously there is the the issue that
has with dental care but you know just
the wider oral health and um and getting
children used to being in the dentist
chair which let's face it none of us
like I can't even bear to see the
pictures that you're running with
people's Street in the dentist chair but
um you know when you're very young it's
very important to get get children used
to being in the dentist chair and we've
heard some some pretty worrying stories
and that's why I say in the report it is
totally unacceptable that in this day
and age still in this situation
well yes and so how bad is the crisis of
access how would you describe that the
scale of the crisis
I'd say the crisis is a sort of three
out of ten I think rarely has there been
an inquiry where I've had such Universal
um approval from committee and from just
people across the house actually
um you know there's a crisis of access
to NHS dentists and and what I would say
is so in many areas so when it comes to
primary care plan
um you know the the choice agenda around
beating down the waiting list the
workforce plan that was produced you
know there are many good positive signs
that this prime minister Chancellor and
health secretary are putting in place
that will I think bear fruit when it
comes to NHS Dentistry not so much and
and fundamentally it comes down to the
government's ambition in this and we
asked the the dentist Dentistry Minister
Neil O'Brien when he was before us you
know what is the actual ambition are you
saying that it's no longer the case that
we ex that we that we are just going to
be able to have NHS Dentistry available
to all he said no no our ambition is
that everybody who wants one should have
access to NHS dentist okay fine happy
with that we're saying the report that
we were pleased and surprised to hear
that ambition because right now we are a
long long way from it and you know to
hear people in such pain distress that
they're pulling out their teeth is is a
huge worry and the problems then
compounded by the by the fact that I
think there's very little information
about what people are entitled to when
it comes to NHS dentistry and I think on
our part we're incredibly frustrated
that our predecessor committee 15 years
ago made very clear recommendations in
this area and they still haven't been
followed up so this spans you know the
last government expands the coalition
government and it spans this my own
government
so what has to be done to achieve that
aim
um well
first of all
I'll keep tinkering around the edges and
to give the government credit they have
made changes to the dental contract and
that's both good and bad and the British
Dental Association would say that yeah
okay uh but but we can't we we're moving
the deck chairs around to the Titanic
with with contract reform the contract
needs completely replacing and without
getting too technical breakfast time you
know what happens at the moment is
dentists are paid around units of dental
activity as opposed to holistic care and
that's one of the reasons why dentists
are leaving the profession so we need a
completely changed contract but but my
concern my sort of half half empty view
if you like is that this happened to me
recently um so many dentists are leaving
doing NHS work because they don't feel
they can offer that holistic
preventative oral health care to their
patients that even if the contract were
changed this morning to what they want
they've made a mental leap which hasn't
been easy for a lot of them because they
trained to go into to NHS practice that
it's going to be very hard to get them
back so we signed the report that as
well as fundamental contract change
there needs to be a big return to NHS
density campaign as we've seen returned
to nursing campaigns so that people come
back and work in the profession because
because right now it's on the brink I I
this is a very complex report there's a
there's a lot of detail in there it's
very very um well evidenced I think but
you know when the British Dental
Association has said that you know this
is an instruction manual to say the NHS
Dentistry I'm that's very kind of them
to say I hope that this government and
the next government of whatever color
picks that up and makes it happen
okay very quickly I just want to ask you
about our latest Westminster accounts
report looking at second jobs you
yourself have worked almost 500 hours in
this Parliament earning a hundred a
thousand pounds all within the rules of
course but how do you think that plays
in public very briefly
I focus on my constituents I focus on
sharing my select committee and I always
have
um and I think you know you should be
very careful about smearing MPS and
making out that MPS are are not focusing
on their jobs 99.9 of MPS I've met in
Westminster are focused on doing their
job and doing the right thing be very
careful into the ground I bet you are
okay
Steve Ryan thanks very much indeed thank
you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone it's eight o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast thousands of
children with special educational needs
are missing out on their schooling as
Sky News reveals staggering delays in
the system well this morning we'll bring
you the story of ten-year-old George
plus just how much are MPS making from
second jobs it's Friday the 14th of July
slipping through the cracks the children
with special educational needs missing
from classrooms because of delays in the
system George has been let down not only
by the school but sometimes I feel like
by me because I'm his mum when I should
be able to give him really simple things
like an education
Sky News reveals the scale of the work
MPS are doing outside of the day job and
who's making the most per hour
[Applause]
Hollywood brought to a standstill actors
have just officially joined writers in
their first joint strike for over 60
years
totally unacceptable calls for Urgent
reform as a report finds people forced
to pull out their own teeth because they
can't see a dentist
a common sweetener is classified as a
possible cancer risk by the World Health
Organization though experts say it's
safe in limited quantities
extreme heat continues to grip southern
Europe as there are warnings that
all-time temperature records could be
broken
foreign
good morning and we start this morning
with a special report on the thousands
of children with special educational
needs or disabilities who are missing
out on the education they're entitled to
because of delays in the system designed
to support them well there are now half
a million children with what's called an
education Health and Care plan a legal
document that sets out extra support
that a child must have well the law is
clear that these plans must be issued
within 20 weeks but that crucial
deadline is missed in half of all cases
meaning thousands of children are being
forced to wait what's guys Nick Martin
speaks to one of the families affected
this is George's story
so we're just me can you open up please
what's wrong George hasn't been to
school for the last six months his mum
Rachel says he could no longer COPE in a
mainstream classroom because of his
complex learning difficulties
to 10 and he can't read or write
this is naming which sounds
the living room is now a classroom and
Rachel who has no teacher training
whatsoever has had to quit her job to
teach her son I'm actually really sad I
think that George has been let down not
only by the school but sometimes I feel
like by me because I'm his mum and I
should
be able to give him really simple things
like an education
and I am struggling to do that what is
this there's a sign here like half a
million other children in England George
has an education Health and Care plan
outlining extra support for special
educational needs and disabilities or
scnd for short by law George's local
Council must provide him with an
education but so far they haven't found
him any alternative provision yet
everything on his educational healthcare
plan should be provided
that's the whole point it's a legal
document saying that George needs this
and this and this and this why on Earth
is it not happening I can't answer that
I don't know Georgia's school told us
they worked with the local Council and
had successfully obtained George's
Education Health and Care plan they said
education is available both in school
and remotely but they added at the time
of writing no additional scnd funding
has been received we asked Essex County
Council why they haven't found George
any alternative provision they said it
would be inappropriate to comment on
individual cases adding any concerns
raised by parents or dealt with
according to our established processes
and we are in touch with the family
directly
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
has announced a special educational
needs Improvement plan but it won't roll
out until after the next election it's
unlikely to help children like George
who are more likely to be absent and who
struggle to get into a special school
due to a shortage of places in 13 years
of government we've known that there has
been pressure in Sen
this lad's 10 years old he could have
been helped if you'd done the
improvements earlier
and now he's not getting an education
you not accept that he has been let down
we did not have the volumes I'm just I
just want to be clear do you accept that
this young lad has been like I I see
people like George in my surgeries a lot
and I spend all my time fighting for a
place in one of our local schools
because I you know I can see that
there's there's three and a half times
over subscribed but the amount of people
needing support as as definitely grown
faster than the capacity do not accept
just naturally accept the fact that this
lad is not going to be helped by your no
you will you will be helpful he won't be
helped as much as we want to as quickly
as we want to sit down
but they sit down
there are thousands of George's
thousands of us that need more help
and we need something to be done
George's education is on hold and as
each day passes he slips further behind
Nick Martin Sky News
now for the latest in our Westminster
accounts series looking at how money
moves through Westminster analysis by
Sky News shows which MPS are spending
the most time working outside Parliament
and how much they make so our Deputy
political editor Sam coats has been
looking into it so so Sam what have you
found so this is day two of the latest
round of the Westminster accounts if
you're Steve Bryan the conservative MP
what we're doing is smearing MPS if your
Sky News we're looking at what the MPS
themselves declare in the register of
members interest but how many hours they
work outside Parliament so here's our
film if you're an MP you might find it
troubling if you're of a sensitive
disposition
what should politicians do with their
time
ban all second jobs for MPS I don't have
any objection to MPS having a an insight
into the outside world second jobs
divide MPS and often anger their voters
you get paid best part of 90 grand a
year that should be enough we've voted
them in to run this country so that's
what they should do Sky News is
Westminster accounts project has
followed the money through our political
system now we reveal the scale of MP's
commitment to their second jobs
for the first time we can show you the
total of how much time MPS say they
spend on their outside work nearly 89
000 hours that's the total amount of
time all MPS have worked in second jobs
over the course of this Parliament so
three and a half years let's see how it
all breaks down these are the MPS who
commit the most hours to their second
jobs
there's some names in there you might
recognize Sir Jeffrey Cox they've become
notorious for their commitment to
outside work but most have one thing in
common all the names on this list have
second jobs in politics councilors
Mayors members of the Scottish
Parliament double political job in
keeping them very busy and something
else we can show you for the very first
time this is the average hourly wage of
an MP in a second job
233 pounds per hour
how does that compare to the rest of the
population well it's a lot higher the
average hourly wage for an MP in a
second job is over 17 times the average
rate for a member of the UK public and
more than 22 times the minimum hourly
wage
which MPS are getting the most cash for
the hours they work this leaderboard
shows you that these 20 MPS have the
highest hourly rates in Parliament the
name of the top is no surprise Boris
Johnson now free to spend even more time
earning big bucks away from Westminster
the second name on this list is the
shortest live PM in British history but
that has hardly dented her earnings
power Liz truss her most lucrative work
since leaving number 10 has been a
speech in Taiwan paid at a rate of 20
000 pounds an hour nearly one and a half
thousand times the UK average hourly
wage for her insights into Global
diplomacy and that's part of a very
common pattern MPS who've served in
government dominate this leaderboard 18
of the MPS with the highest hourly
earnings this Parliament have government
experience clearly a very lucrative
addition to any parliamentarian CV
plans for major second job reforms have
Frozen in this Parliament is it just a
matter of time until voters force a
change Samco Sky News
so Sam these second jobs are all within
the rules so should we be surprised
um on one level no this has been a
particular issue in this Parliament
because some of the most high-profile
scandals that we've seen like the Owen
Patterson one refer back to it and and I
don't think
um it is that tough a watch for MPS I
don't think it is a smear I think what's
important uh even if you find the
subject uncomfortable discuss to discuss
if you're an MP is being able to justify
it and what's interesting is you've got
some figures on that leaderboard like
Jeffrey Cox who are very robust both
about the amount of time they spend
outside Parliament he says it's good for
democracy and the rate that he's paid he
Compares it uh to a cabinet minister
ministerial jobs of course in their own
right are second jobs of a different
form
um but I think what's striking about
today's data is a couple of things
um first of all just how many of the
biggest household names in politics are
those that at the top of the leaderboard
now on one level that's not surprising
because former Prime Ministers for
example are the kind of people that
would command the highest sums but
they're also the people that set the
example for the rest of them and you've
got Boris Johnson now no longer an MPS
trust Theresa may they all feature very
highly on those leaderboards
um one of the other things that's uh
quite notable is just how many people
um and it's completely accepted in
Westminster uh are doing second jobs in
other parliaments like Douglas Ross is
uh is actually top of the list of people
who commits themselves to the most
number of hours now sort of Westminster
just decided that that's not
controversial uh that the practice of
doing other things isn't even in of
itself inherently uh problematic maybe
this uh data will um throw up a
discussion about whether or not that uh
that attitude should continue yeah
interesting Sam thanks very much indeed
now Hollywood's film and TV industry
will effectively shut down as access
join screenwriters in officially going
on strike it follows a collapse in talks
with Studios and streaming companies
over pay conditions and concerns over
the use of artificial intelligence
Martha Kellner has the latest
this is the first time in 63 years that
both the writers and the actors in
Hollywood have been on strike at the
same time and it is relatively Uncharted
Territory I was down at a picket line
with writers who have been on strike now
for two months and a huge cheer erupted
as they learned the news that the actors
who bring their words to life would be
joining them on strike because they know
that this makes their bargaining
position with the Production Studios and
the streaming Giants all that much
stronger we've already seen this taking
effect it's not just the film and TV
production that stops almost immediately
it's the bells and whistles around this
industry the things like the premieres
uh the the Pressed John kits the photo
shoots Oppenheimer Premiere in London
the Stars had already walked the red
carpet when they got news that this
strike was happening the likes of Emily
Blunt and Killian Murphy walked away
from that event straight away it's clear
that many many actors are very committed
to this cause and in fact I barely heard
a whisper from anyone within the acting
Community who doesn't think that this is
the right course of action and this
campaign has been led by the likes of
Jennifer Lawrence Meryl Streep Mark
Ruffalo they were all signatories to a
letter urging their Union to take a hard
line and this is where We've Ended up
with a dual strike for actors and
writers
people are being forced to pull out
their own teeth at home because they
can't afford or access an NHS dentist
that's according to a new report by the
health select committee which found DIY
extractions have been performed with
pliers in some cases While others have
been forced to make a five-hour round
trip to see a professional the committee
recommends updating current contracts
with dentists and launching a public
information campaign to explain how NHS
Dentistry works the committee's chair
Steve Bryan told me it's a failure of
successive governments to hear people in
such pain and distress that they're
pulling out their teeth is is a huge
worry and the problems then compounded
by the by the fact that I think there's
very little information about what
people are entitled to when it comes to
NHS dentistry and I think on our part
we're incredibly frustrated that our
predecessor committee 15 years ago made
very clear recommendations in this area
and they still haven't been followed up
so this spans you know the last
government it's about the coalition
government and it spans this my own
government
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and the funeral of
one of the victims of last month's
attacks in Nottingham is taking place
today 19 year old Barnaby Weber was
walking home from a night out with
fellow student Grace O'Malley Kumar when
they were stabbed to death a 31 year old
man has been charged with their murders
and will face trial in January
Hollywood actor Kevin Spacey will be
cross-examined in his sexual assault
trial the Oscar winner has started
giving evidence to court claiming he was
flirtatious and romantic with one of his
alleged victims he's previously denied
all 12 charges against him relating to
four men between 2001 and 2013.
Health authorities in the U.S have
approved a birth control pill for sale
without a prescription for the first
time ever Opel also labeled the mini
pill contains just one hormone and has
been used under prescription since 1973.
Hollywood may now be on strike and today
junior doctors in England are preparing
to strike for a second day too well the
government said there'll be no more
negotiations after offering a six
percent salary rise in line with
independent pay review bodies but the
BMA wants 35 percent or the government's
offer does now mean that millions of
other UK public sector workers will get
a pay rise police in England and Wales
will get a seven percent pay rise and
the same goes for prison officers and
the armed forces are to get five percent
as well as an additional 1 000 pounds
Consolidated increase
NHS Consultants specialist doctors
salaried dentists and GPS in England
will get six percent
the same as Junior doctors as well as a
one-off increase of 1 250 pounds and
teachers in England will be given a six
and a half percent pay rise teaching
unions have now suspended all their
planned strikes
but School budgets won't be able to
fully fit the bill for those pay Rises
so where in the department of education
is that money going to come from well
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
explained earlier
what happens in in government budgeting
is if you don't spend it all and very
often you don't spend it all because you
overestimate how quickly you can roll
things out Etc then all that money
usually goes back to the treasury and
what's happened in in this case and the
treasury of work with us to enable us to
do that as they've given us the
flexibility to take those uh anticipated
underspends and to move them into
Teachers Pay so if it's come from an
underspend that's okay for this year but
but what about
future years as well we've looked at
Future years so we've looked at this
year and next year which are the two
years that are left within the spending
review and then of course it gets
Consolidated into the spending review
and that's what happens every year with
everything actually how confident are
you that teachers will accept that given
that it's still below inflation which is
at 8.7 percent
um I mean it's the unions really that
have got the best judgment on that and
and they they seem to be uh confident uh
that their members will do that but of
course it will have to go to the ballot
well I also spoke to the General
Secretary of the trades Union Congress
Paul Novak and he says in some parts of
the public sector there's little Clarity
over where the money will come from
I know for example uh in health the the
hospital consultants and Specialists
Association at TUC at Union is concerned
about you know effectively the salami
slicing of NHS funding Robin Peter to
pay Paul to fund any pay rise and so
they're still calling on the government
to sit round and negotiate so I think it
looks very different in different parts
of the public sector but I think overall
uh I I would say that the Prime Minister
and him accepting those pay review body
Awards wouldn't have happened if union
members hadn't stood up uh taking that
really difficult decision to vote for
strike action and show the government
that they weren't prepared to accept
getting other uh real terms papers
well our political correspondent Rob
Powell is back with me now so this
announcement Yesterday by the government
that they would back the pay review
bodies came as a surprise to some people
because it wasn't guaranteed that they
would but has it gone down yeah that's
definitely the good news that the
governments are pushing forward on
teachers and Jillian Keegan this morning
saying that she got the sense that union
members would back this of course it
will go out to a ballot now and we've
seen in the past where leaders of unions
have been urging members to back it but
then they've had a different idea so we
wait to see whether the actual Rank and
file teachers think this is a good
enough deal Jillian Keegan also said
that schools would get the money they
needed to fund this pay rise and that's
important because school leaders said
look if you're not giving us extra money
for these pay Rises then the money will
have to come up come from other bits of
uh where you run schools
um I think though it will lead some to
question whether the government's
spending plans more broadly after 2024
are realistic given that they are very
very tight and you are now seeing big
pay rate prices like this that will be
baked in year after year and will be
needed to be funded somehow so I think
the teachers is the good news for the
government the not so good news is
clearly what's going on with Junior
doctors because that offer that came
through yesterday for them has
essentially been rejected already from
the BMA there are strikes walkouts going
on right now and we really looking look
to be in a sort of standoff stalemate
whereby the Prime Minister says no more
talks but the BMA says that it won't
accept this so the logical conclusion
from that is that we are going to get
more rolling strikes continuing for the
months ahead uh bad news for patients
bad news for the government though as
well when one of Russia's unex five
priorities is cutting waiting lists to
have people walking out potentially
until the end of the year yeah really
interesting to see how that's going to
play out Rob thanks very much
now countries in southern Europe are
preparing emergency measures as a heat
wave that has gripped the region it's
expected to break record temperatures in
Greece the government has ordered work
to stop between 12 and 5 in the
afternoon in areas where the risk from
heat is very high well our energy and
climate change correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter is in the Greek city of
perea so Hannah what kind of impact then
are these higher temperatures having
there
well I think there's two layers of
impact the first is the immediate crisis
public health impact obviously the Greek
authorities are taking this prolonged
Heat Wave very seriously they're saying
people should avoid the heat of the day
if they can they certainly shouldn't be
working outside food deliveries are
going to be stopped public buildings are
being closed it may well be that some of
the historical monuments are also closed
through the heat of the day today as
well there are concerns about
very vulnerable people getting sick in
this heat so there's been a big
messaging campaign around that there are
also real concerns in this country about
wildfires particularly as the wind
starts to pick up in a couple of days
time combined with this heat Greece had
a terrible Wildfire season last year and
authorities are really Keen to avoid a
repeat of what happened but then the
secondary layer is perhaps more damaging
as climate change scientists tell us
that the world is warming Europe is
warming at twice the rate of the rest of
the planet these more extreme weather
events are here to stay they're becoming
more and more likely and longer in
duration there's the economic impact
people aren't able to do their jobs be
outside go about their business it
changes the way people approach their
day and that economic impact is a real
problem for governments as they try and
grapple with the new reality which is
how Greece's climate Minister described
this situation to me yesterday
please
now almost 300 children are believed to
have died or disappeared this year
whilst attempting to cross the
Mediterranean Sea new research by UNICEF
estimates that around 11 600 children
have made the dangerous Crossing so far
in 2023 and that the majority were alone
well let's speak now to Varina Klaus
whose global migration and displacement
lead at UNICEF a very good morning to
you thanks so much for talking to this
morning and you have your report out
today so run us through what the key
findings of that report are
good morning and thank you very much
well the key findings really are that
there is a shocking and fast-growing
number of children that are trying to
reach safety crossing the sea from North
Africa to Europe the number has doubled
in the first six months of this year
compared to last year and as the numbers
of children who tried to take the
journey to reunite with families or seek
protection is increasing so do the
numbers of death it's a shocking
inaction that we're seeing play out here
where we seem to be turning a blind eye
to daily reports of children literally
drowning in front of our eyes if you
break these figures down it actually
means that we have around 11 children
dying at Sea right in front of our
Shores make the mouth it's nearly two
children a day this means that you know
so many lives there are absolutely so
many deaths that are preventable so many
lives that could be rescued
um are just being lost day in and day
out and we just don't seem to be taking
it seriously enough
well yes and give us an idea of just how
common it is for children to make these
Journeys on their own unaccompanied or
separated from their parents what what
statistics do you have on that
yes indeed as you as you said there has
also been a real real significant
increase of the number of children that
are taking that high risk Journey on
their own so in the first three months
of this year compared to last year the
number of children that are getting on a
boat traveling alone has increased by
three times so that means that around 71
percent of those children who who cross
and who die are actually unaccompanied
so they drown on their own with no
parent around
but yes and what are the other risks
associated with these Journeys clearly
the risk of drowning should the boats
capsize if there are shipwrecks but what
are the other dangers that children face
well I think what we are what we are
seeing is there is a growing number of
conflicts around the world that is
thriving this growing number of children
that have seen no other option than to
get on a unsafe boat and to take the
risks including the risk of possibly
drowning to reach Shores where they can
seek Asylum where they can reunite with
family members conflicts in Afghanistan
conflicts in Sudan but also the growing
impacts of the climate crisis many
countries in the world and we have
numbers of children growing up from
Somalia from Ethiopia they're living in
areas that are increasingly becoming
uninhabitable because of heat waves
droughts the impacts of the climate
crisis so all of these factors are one
part of what is driving children from
their homes but also it is government
policies it is decisions taken in Europe
decisions taken across the countries
that are you know bordering the
Mediterranean that are driving the high
number of deaths because these children
have no legal way no safe way to get on
a plane to apply for family
reunification to have their claim
processed and properly assessed that is
why they are turning to these unsafe
routes that is why they are taking these
risks so the sea Journey itself is
deadly as the numbers are telling us but
many of these children they actually
experience beatings they're experiencing
detention rape the experiencing
atrocious sexual violence on their
Journey but also as they're waiting in
the countries like Libya or Egypt to
actually try to make the crossing so
this is really a call to action if we if
we are comfortable with the fact that
300 children drown and die in just six
months alone this is just unacceptable
and there are many many very practical
Solutions we need to expand the
opportunities for children to be able to
Lodge their applications so they can
reunite with families that's a right in
the convention on the rights of the
child we need to also expand seriously
search and rescue capacities it is not
acceptable that Europe is watching as
children are drowning but we also need
to cooperate across the sea children
need to be able to turn to Child
Protection authorities in the countries
of Transit and when they arrive in
Europe so they get protected by
government authorities and they do not
feel the need to turn to Smugglers who
do not have their best interests at
their heart so the solutions are there
but it takes political will it takes
Investments and first of all it means we
need to care we cannot turn away as
every day almost two children drown and
die in the sea where we all go on
holidays in the next few weeks
Wolverine canals from UNICEF thank you
very much indeed for your time this
morning we appreciate it thank you
thank you
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well there's a heat wave for southern
Europe but the rather cool and unsettled
conditions here will continue
unseasonably strong winds in the south
over the next few days may bring some
disruption meanwhile it's a maybe dry
start to the north but Wind and Rain are
taking over more of the South the rest
of Southern Britain Ireland and Northern
Ireland will see rain through the
morning heavier times and further north
expect some brighter more showery
conditions it'll be rather cool and
windy with the strongest winds in the
southwest where Coastal Gales are
possible
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up on Sky News breakfast after a
tricky few months for the SMP their
former Westminster leader in Blackford
sets a vision for Scotland's future
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
breakfast a reminder of our top stories
here this morning thousands of children
with special educational needs or
disabilities are missing out on
schooling because of delays in Council
issued Education Health and Care plans
[Music]
Sky News Westminster accounts
investigation has found MPS with second
jobs earn an average wage of 233 pounds
per hour that's more than 22 times
higher than the minimum hourly wage
in Hollywood actors join screenwriters
in strikes starting this hour which
threatened to bring the film and TV
Industries to a halt
and I wanna
now the World Health Organization has
formally ruled a common artificial
sweetener used in diet soft drinks as a
possible carcinogen but won't change its
Health guidance well joining me now is
Skies Thomas Moore so Thomas explain to
us what this warning actually means
practically yeah this is involves one of
the most widely used artificial
sweeteners it's called aspartame and if
you go into any Supermarket you're going
to see it in lots of low calorie low
sugar foods and drinks ranging from Diet
Coke to Wrigley's Extra Gum to Muller
light yogurts I mean it is there so it's
really important that we know that it's
safe and one World Health Organization
body has now looked at it and they
categorize something like a thousand
substances so far into the likelihood
that they cause cancer and this is how
they've arrived at the conclusion that
aspartame may possibly cause cancer that
sounds alarming but they look they rank
things right at the top are the things
that definitely cause cancer things like
tobacco and alcohol followed that is
ones that probably cause cancer things
like red meat and then you come down to
the category they were talking about
possible links to cancer aspartame aloe
vera and some other things like that so
it sounds alarming but in fact this
really is based on the the strength of
the scientific evidence and you have to
look at that and if it's possible that
it might be linked to cancer then you'd
think that that evidence is weak they're
not clear at all that there is a risk
now there's another body that's linked
to the United Nations which has tried to
turn all that into real world
advice that we can use and and they've
concluded that it would be perfectly
acceptable for some for an adult
weighing about 70 kilos to to consume up
to 14 cans of of diet fizzy drink and
for a child to consume a 10 year old
child weighs about 32 kilograms that
they they would be able to consume six
and a half something like that so most
people will be well below the limit even
if they are breaching that limit it's
still not definite that aspartame would
be definitely causing cancer so I think
you can be reassured unless you're
consuming vast of quantities of
aspartame
Thomas thanks very much indeed
now the smps Ian Blackford has unfailed
a green road map that he says will
transform Scotland's economy and
Industry at the former party leader in
Westminster says the paper will allow
the Scottish government to demonstrate
why people should have confidence in an
independent Scotland and Ian joins me
now very good morning to you so yes you
set out to see if there was a green
industrial future for Scotland and
you've written a report you've got it
with you so what did you find well you
know the starting point to this I
actually probably said report last year
about Scotland's green energy potential
and what we argued in that is that we
could increase our output five-fold what
this report does is take that on and
talks about how we build the supply
chain and I guess everything that's
happened since then that the war in
Ukraine that's taking place to desire
for energy security so there's a real
race you can see in North America you
can see in Europe and we've got to make
sure that Scotland is in the right place
to benefit from that we'll be about five
percent of the global offshore wind
market so people don't have to come and
invest in Scotland we need to make sure
that they want want to do that that we
can get the supply chain jobs we don't
make the mistakes if I may say so that
we made with oil and gas that we get the
full benefit of this and I think there
are some encouraging signs already we've
seen the investment by Sumitomo in a
cabling manufacturing facility in the
highlands but we need more of that and
what we're saying to the Scottish
government is that we need to work
collaboratively with those in Industry
with those in Academia make sure we're
driving The Innovation get the key
people around the table and the first
minister to host a strategic Industrial
Council you know when I when I look in
the rear view mirror and I've referenced
a book by a chap called Anderson that
shows that Scotland has lost relative
population share every decade in the UK
since the 1850s we have to change the
record we have to show that we're
serious about sustainable economic
growth green energy transforms our
ability to grow and it's about how we
deliver on that how we also benefit from
our academic Excellence which is the
other theme which is contained within
the report okay so people will want to
know what a green Energy Future means
for North Sea oil we've seen labor
mooting plans on to ban new expiration
do you agree with that I think what we
need to do is actually show people we
have a proper roadmap Anna and of course
oil and gas is an important part of the
the mix over the course of the short to
medium term what we're talking about but
look what we need to do I think what we
need to do is look at the demand side of
things so we need to look at how we ramp
up green energy production I mean I've
talked about that five-fold increase by
2050. if we can if we can decarbonize
our economy we will reduce our our
dependency in oil and gas and that's
really the question that we need to ask
and then it's a question of what is the
outturn in oil and gas production we
need to make sure that we transition
effectively we've got a lot of jobs in
oil and gas 70 odd thousand in the
energy report that I published last year
we talked about getting to 325 000 jobs
in Green energy so it's about that
transition and how we actually over that
Journey we reduce our dependency oil but
it remains a key part of the mix of over
the short and medium term but reducing
your dependency on North Sea oil is that
a tacit admission that Independence is
not looking like it's on the cards
certainly in the short term given that
the uh the money from nausea oil was
always a key part of the economic plan
for Independence look at the end of the
day I think there's a there's that
question about what happened to the
Bounty from nausea oil there was 350
billion of tax receipts and where has it
gone what we're trying to do in this
paper is to make sure that we can
deliver that sustainable economic growth
in Scotland that we can get the
investment we can drive up productivity
we can get the tax receipts and I think
through that give confidence to people
in Scotland that we have got the vision
as to what an economy of an independent
Scotland will look like and in some
respects I would turn this around and
say when is the industrial strategy for
the UK it doesn't exist he does an
effective plan and it's multifaceted you
can talk about offshore wind I went to
see a plan for title for example and I'm
calling on the key government because it
has reserved powers to make sure we
support that industry let's get the
investment in carbon capture and storage
you know one of the things I talked
about if I made just briefly in Academia
we bring lots of students over to
Scotland we train them we educate them
and then we ask them to go home that's
clearly Insanity we won't need to make
sure that we've got the talent that can
help Drive our economy and we need to
have an effective post-study work visa
so there's so many things that we can do
take the right decisions that will allow
us to deliver economic growth okay and
I'm sure that the government will be
pouring over your report in the meantime
though you've announced you're stepping
down at the next election six other SNP
MPS have actually followed you in making
the same decision is this a crisis for
the SMP no it's not and I think
hopefully you can see this morning the
enthusiasm I have for this I want to
make sure although I'm not going to be
an MP I'm still playing a part I want to
support the first minister in the
delivery of his economic plans because
that's that's what it will be you know
I've been in the SNP since the 1970s and
I want to make sure and they're not too
different distant future that we finish
that journey to Independence and while I
may not be an MP I'm still certainly
going to be playing my full part in that
your colleague Murray black said she was
stepping down as an MP partly because of
what she described as a toxic working
environment you've obviously worked at
Westminster as well do you recognize
what she's saying I think it's been a
challenging period everything that we're
going through brexit in particular in
the whole atmosphere in the place we
need to make sure that people can come
to Westminster can do their job they can
do that with respect and Trust across
the place and it's you know I'd say it's
quite sad that we're using losing people
of young people effectively of of talent
such as Maddie we need to make sure that
Parliament can be a place that's
welcoming to people and they can show
their towns to the fullest extent and as
you leave I wonder if you can reflect on
some of the rules in Westminster because
today our Westminster accounts is
looking at second jobs for energy so
we're going to take a look at yours
um all in the public domain these um
these figures and of course all
completely within the rules and but you
have done 31 hours of work in this
current Parliament at an average of 1
200 pounds per hour
do you think the rules are appropriate
well Anna when I came into Parliament I
had two non-executive directorships two
chairmanships and I said at the last
election that I would wind those up and
I did that very very early in this
Parliament I think it was done by the by
the end of the first quarter of that
Parliament so these were these were kind
of Legacy issues if you if you like
there is I think a legitimate debate
about earnings of of MPS I've actually
just gone on to the committee of
standards and public life and I'm sure
all of these things that we will we will
reflect on because I think it is
important that the the public can have
trust and those that they they send to
Parliament well yes and and what we
found is that MPS were second jobs have
an average wage of 233 pounds per hour
that's 17 times the national average
yeah do you think that will sit
comfortably with people you know you've
seen obviously the likes of Boris
Johnson this trust Aaron eye-watering
sums of money on the speaking circuit
benefiting from the position that they
had as as prime minister and I think
rightly people were appalled that that
kind of behavior I think it's important
that we can trust our our politicians
and I think people have to look very
carefully at what they do being an MP is
a very important job it is a full-time
job
um of course at the end of the day
you're you're accountable to your
electorate when you stand in front of
them at the at the next election I think
most MPS do work very hard it is an
all-consuming job but yeah absolutely
let's make sure that there's food
transparency in this that people are not
abusing the Privileges that's put in
them as as members of parliament very
quickly you mentioned Boris Johnson what
do you make of the fact that his older
phone is not being handed over at the
moment to the covert inquiry we're told
it's I mean I find this extraordinary
that he can't remember the past the
passcode for his phone really
um you know I think we need to have that
full transparency in in this inquiry and
I think it's important that these
messages that are on that phone are
accessible to the inquiry okay in
Blackford thanks very much for coming in
we appreciate your time this morning my
pleasure thank you
now then it's men's semi-finals day at
Wimbledon uh what have the grass course
got in store Jackie can tell us she's uh
in our other studio for us this morning
I thought you're a Wimbledon last hour
but you're not you're in in the warm so
Jackie what can we expect today
yeah hiding from the rain I am uh yes
well
I would imagine that Djokovic is going
to win this first semi-final against
Yannick sinner Yannick sinner
is so very young 21 I mean he is very
Steely but when you look at him he looks
like he's escaped from sixth form
college and someone's handed him a
racket I mean he is you know he is a
very sort of tall young thin looking man
and he's got great supporters called the
carotos the karata boys who dress like
carrots and follow him around because
he's got Ginger hair was an incredibly
good skier when he was younger and then
picked tennis and my goodness he is very
very very good at tennis he whacks the
ball uh considering you know he is so
slight I think Djokovic has got too much
experience for him in this one and
Djokovic of course going for eight one
wooden titles in all five in a row I
mean he just seems Unstoppable and in
the the other semi that's more open I
suppose Carlos the world number one from
Spain also very young just 20
um up against Daniel Medvedev who
couldn't play last year because of the
Russian band he's also got something to
prove I suppose that one is more open
but I think the final that everyone
would like to see is Djokovic against al
caraz but Djokovic is the man who is
supremely confident I don't want to
sound arrogant but of course I don't
consider myself favorite you know
you know judging with for the the
results that I had in the in the my
career here and in previous
four
occasions of Wimbledon that I won you
know uh and reaching another semi-final
so I do consider myself favorite yes
well the women's final is tomorrow and
that is going to give us a brand new
champion on the Venus rose water dish uh
tunisia's on jabber produce an amazing
comeback in her semi to beat the second
seed Arena zabalenka she will meet
Marquetta Von drussa for tomorrow the
first unseated player to reach the
women's singles final in the open era I
think she's probably the most tattooed
player as well the Czech player beating
the very popular Ukrainian Elena
svitolina in straight set so that is
Wimbledon it is the business end of that
championships but there's lots of other
sport going on as well let's have a look
Sky News sports bulletin is brought to
you by vitality
getting more people more active live
life with vitality
[Applause]
Wimbledon in full bloom one of the most
glorious scenes in all of sport
to place this man has got to know well
cam Nori cycled to the Championships and
all the way to the last four last year
so how much does he feel sustainability
time to find out here he is
hey cam how are you doing very well
thank you good to see you nice to see
you what is it like to be back here
can't complain so nice especially when
the weather's like this yeah so do you
fancy having a little wander around
reliving some memories chat a bit of
climate let's do it let's do it come on
[Music]
Court 16. talk to me yeah I remember
that she was my first ever main draw
men's win here so very special court for
me what did that feel like did it
it's a major moment for you I think it
was one of those days I was so nervous
for the match so tight because I never
won a match here
um and I just really wanted to get over
the line so I think it was more of a
relief more than like enjoying it so
what about climate and climate change
when did you first sort of have exposure
to this topic I guess yeah actually I
remember taking a sustainability class
at TCU where I went to University in the
states and one of the things that stood
up for me was I don't know why but it
was in the Netherlands how many people
biked to work there and I was thinking
like for me why can't I do the same and
and around London when I'm I'm here I'm
biking to practice and definitely it's a
good warm-up good cool down and yeah
growing up in New Zealand everyone's
pretty conscious of of everything
they're protecting the beaches and and
my parents the Sky News sports bulletin
is brought to you by vitality
Jackie thanks very much indeed still to
come here on Sky News breakfast on
another baking day across southern
Europe a climate scientist tells us
whether extreme heat will be the new
normal
[Music]
a lot of action going on I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
makes
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Sky's Chief correspondent well there's a
real sense now that people are beginning
to expect that this whole airlift is
coming to an end and they're really
really desperate
we saw snatch words going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
wall
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
is really sending a clear message that
Venezuela is eager for change
we've been crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
convinced the United States will become
hooked we're all right
we're normal six stations come down I
think it was just landed in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in Iraq and
Syria but across the world
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
total control business people drawing so
so hot
[Music]
well let's return to that heat wave
which is affecting countries in southern
Europe temperatures are currently
expected to be higher than 40 degrees in
parts of Spain France Greece Croatia and
turkey
well joining me now is Joffrey
carnissier who's a climate scientist and
contributor to the intergovernmental
panel on climate change a very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us I know you're joining us
from Barcelona so first of all how hot
is it there and how long are you
expecting the extreme temperatures to
continue
well over the last days the temperatures
have been extreme over 40 degrees in
many areas now the situation is getting
better and it's it's this hip wave event
is somehow passing by and moving to the
Eastern areas of the Mediterranean and
more strongly affecting Italy and other
areas
and what can we read into this very high
temperatures is it possible to be to
attribute a particular weather event
like this to climate change
yes it is and uh there's a an entire
field in climate science which is called
attribution studies and and after some
calculation is this possible uh to in a
specific studies to attribute these
unprecedented events to climate change
and there's a lot of scientific evidence
that is demonstrating that that all
these uh hit extreme heat waves events
are closely connected to climate change
as their main cause
so do we have to get used to very hot
summers like this in in parts of Europe
yes indeed the prediction of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
will indicates that is a risk that that
we will experience although it's also in
our hands to modulate this risk if we
reduce the emissions the greenhouse gas
emissions over the next two decades
these impacts would be greatly
diminished and it's a bit in our hands
yet if we react and at taking
um
policies uh mainly directed to reduce
their emissions
is climate change playing out as you'd
expected or in unpredictable ways
well this is an open feeling saying so
uh
in over the last decades the the trends
that we have been observing has been
gradually matching what was predicted by
the initial reports in the 80s and 90s
by the ipcc
so it's it's behaving in this way but we
we could Forefront also unexpected
scenarios because uh it's uh there's
some deep uncertainty in the future
scenarios and we cannot uh disregard or
discard uh non-linear phenomena or
unprecedented phenomena that were not
closely predicted so yes the science has
been successful in predicting the
current trends but we cannot discard
unexpected scenarios according to the
current science that that we have
a new study out this week so that the UK
was one of the countries that would have
to adapt the most radically to to cool
down buildings as climate change drives
up a global average temperatures they
say that like other countries in in
northern Europe buildings were designed
when they were built to keep the heat in
in the winter how much does need to
happen to adapt to to changing weather
patterns
yes that's that's truly like the UK and
other Northern countries uh are not Wall
Street or prepared for this situation
and they will need to invest in in in in
Sheltering all these uh sometimes all
buildings and and investing a lot
because it's hugely impacting uh the the
health of the population and especially
elderly people
okay well Joffrey o'connicio it's very
interesting to hear your take on it all
thanks very much indeed for joining us
it's a pleasure
's up to here
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
so there's a heat wave for southern
Europe but the rather cool and unsettled
conditions here are going to continue
unseasonably strong winds in the south
over the next few days may also bring
some disruption it's a mainly dry start
in the north but Wind and Rain are
taking over more of the South and the
rest of Southern Britain Ireland and
Northern Ireland will see rain
throughout the morning heavy at times
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now the site of butterflies fluttering
amongst summertime flowers maybe a
dyllic but it's coming under threat from
climate change
so let's take a look at some butterflies
though there are some researchers say
years of record temperatures heat waves
and drought in the UK have caused some
of the plans that caterpillars plants
that caterpillars feed on to wither and
die and that's having an impact on our
butterfly population four in five
species have declined in numbers since
the 1970s and climate change could make
things even worse in the years to come
with half of our butterfly species
already at risk of Extinction we're
going to be talking about this a little
bit more with uh Chris Packham coming up
in the next hour as well as all our top
stories so don't go away
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's nine o'clock you're watching Sky
News breakfast thousands of children
with special educational needs are
missing out on their schooling a Sky
News reveals staggering delays in the
system this morning we'll bring you the
story of 10 year old George
plus just how much are MPS making from
second jobs the former leader of the SMP
in Westminster tells me it's important
people have trust in their elective
Representatives it's Friday the 14th of
July
slipping through the cracks the children
with special educational needs missing
from classrooms because of delays in the
system
George has been let down not only by the
school but sometimes I feel like by me
because I'm his mum and I should be able
to give him really simple things like an
education
Sky News reveals the scale of the work
MPS are doing outside the day job amid
calls for more transparency
there is I think a legitimate debate
about earnings of MPS I've actually just
gone on to the committee of standards
and public life and I'm sure all of
these things that we will we will
reflect on
[Applause]
Hollywood brought to a standstill actors
have just officially joined writers in
their first joint strike for over 60
years
totally unacceptable calls for reform as
a report finds people forced to pull out
their own teeth because they can't see a
dentist
the common sweetener is classified as a
possible cancer risk by the World Health
Organization though experts say it's
safe in limited quantities
stream heat continues to grip southern
Europe as there are warnings that
all-time temperature records could be
broken
foreign
good morning and we start today with a
special report on the thousands of
children with special educational needs
or disabilities who are missing out on
the education they're entitled to
because of delays in the system designed
to support them there are now half a
million children with what's called an
education Health and Care plan that's a
legal document that sets out extra
support that a child must have well the
law is clear that these plans must be
issued within 20 weeks but that crucial
deadline is missed in half of all cases
meaning thousands of children are being
forced to wait
well Skies Nick Martin speaks to one of
the families affected this is George's
story
George it's me can you open up please
sure George hasn't been to school for
the last six months his mum at Rachel
says he could no longer COPE in a
mainstream classroom because of his
complex learning difficulties he's 10
and he can't read or write
this is naming which sounds
the living room is now a classroom and
Rachel who has no teacher training
whatsoever has had to quit her job to
teach her son I'm actually really sad I
think that George has been let down not
only by the school but sometimes I feel
like by me because I'm his mum and I
should
be able to give him really simple things
like an education
and I am struggling to do that what is
this there's a sign here like half a
million other children in England George
has an education Health and Care plan
outlining extra support for special
educational needs and disabilities or
scnd for short by law George's local
Council must provide him with an
education but so far they haven't found
him any alternative provision yet
everything on his educational healthcare
plan should be provided
that's the whole point it's a legal
document saying that George needs this
and this and this and this why on Earth
is it not happening I can't answer that
I don't know Georgia's school told us
they worked with the local Council and
had successfully obtained Georgia's
Education Health and Care plan they said
education is available both in school
and remotely but they added at the time
of writing no additional scnd funding
has been received we asked Essex County
Council why they haven't found George
any alternative provision they said it
would be inappropriate to comment on
individual cases adding any concerns
raised by parents or dealt with
according to our established processes
and we are in touch with the family
directly
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
has announced a special educational
needs Improvement plan but it won't roll
out until after the next election it's
unlikely to help children like George
who are more likely to be absent and who
struggle to get into a special school
due to a shortage of places in 13 years
of government we've known that there has
been pressure in Sen
this lad's 10 years old he could have
been helped if you'd done the
improvements earlier
and now he's not getting an education
you not accept that he has been let down
we did not have the volumes I'm just I
just want to be clear do you accept that
this young lad has been like I I see
people like George in my surgeries a lot
and I spend all my time fighting for a
place in one of our local schools
because I you know I can see that
there's there's three and a half times
over subscribed but the amount of people
needing support as as definitely grown
faster than the capacity do not accept
just naturally accept the fact that this
lad is not going to be helped by your no
you will you will be helpful he won't be
helped as much as we want to as quickly
as we want to sit down
ready sit down
there are thousands of George's
thousands of us that need more help
and we need something to be done
George's education is on hold and as
each day passes he slips further behind
Nick Martin Sky News
now it's time for the latest in our
Westminster account series looking at
how money moves through Westminster so
analysis by Sky News shows which MPS are
spending the most time working outside
Parliament and how much they make so our
Deputy political editor Sam coats has
been looking into it so what have you
found that MPS of a sensitive
disposition should turn away now naming
no names uh Westminster accounts is back
this is the second big installment and
today what we've been doing is releasing
the results of an attempt to go through
the registered members interests which
is where MPS record their earnings uh
for second jobs and in that they have to
say how many hours they work in jobs
that are not being a backbedge MP we
took the data put it in a spreadsheet
analyzed it and here are the results
what should politicians do with their
time
ban all second jobs for MPS I don't have
any objection to MPS having a an insight
into the outside world second jobs
divide MPS and often anger their voters
you get paid best part of 90 grand a
year should be enough we've voted them
in to run this country so that's what
they should do Sky News is Westminster
accounts project has followed the money
through our political system now we
reveal the scale of MP's commitment to
their second jobs
for the first time we can show you the
total of how much time MPS say they
spend on their outside work nearly 89
000 hours that's the total amount of
time all MPS have worked in second jobs
over the course of this Parliament so
three and a half years let's see how it
all breaks down these are the MPS who
commit the most hours to their second
jobs
there's some names in there you might
recognize Sir Jeffrey Cox they've become
notorious for their commitment to
outside work but most have one thing in
common all the names on this list have
second jobs in politics counselors
Mayors members of the Scottish
Parliament double political job in
keeping them very busy and something
else we can show you for the very first
time this is the average hourly wage of
an MP in a second job
233 pounds per hour
how does that compare to the rest of the
population well it's a lot higher the
average hourly wage for an MP in a
second job is over 17 times the average
rate for a member of the UK public and
more than 22 times the minimum hourly
wage
which MPS are getting the most cash for
the hours they work this leaderboard
shows you that these 20 MPS have the
highest hourly rates in Parliament the
name of the top is no surprise Boris
Johnson now free to spend even more time
earning big bucks away from Westminster
the second name on this list is the
shortest live PM in British history but
that has hardly dented her earnings
power Liz truss her most lucrative work
since leaving number 10 has been a
speech in Taiwan paid at a rate of 20
000 pounds an hour nearly one and a half
thousand times the UK average hourly
wage for her insights into Global
diplomacy and that's part of a very
common pattern MPS who've served in
government dominate this leaderboard 18
of the MPS with the highest hourly
earnings this Parliament have government
experience clearly a very lucrative
addition to any parliamentarian CV
plans for major second job reforms have
Frozen in this Parliament is it just a
matter of time until voters force a
change
and and some I've spoken to a few MPS
this morning and put this issue to them
and and some feel don't they they feel a
bit irritated by being asked about this
they say it's completely within the
rules and you're just doing down MPS
um that's right some do you think that
of the three MPS you spoke to broadly
speaking one said not me gov that was
student kid in the education secretary
one said how dare you that was Steve
Bryan uh and one Ian Blackford said
there needs to be some reform there are
MPS that get irritated by this stuff so
let's start uh by just listening to a
little bit of Steve Bryan who was not
impressed by your questions
I focus on my constituents I focus on
sharing my select committee and I always
have
um and I think you know you should be
very careful about sneering MPS and
making out that MPS are are not focusing
on their jobs 99.9 of MPS I've met in
Westminster are focused on doing their
job and doing the right thing be very
careful into the ground I bet you are
okay
he was not happy and we were out of time
we were we were out of time but the
sarcastic comment at the end I think
from him said a lot that the point is
that MPS are free to do outside jobs if
they wish um you know and there are some
parameters Set uh for them and they if
they follow the rules they can they can
do this and the attempts at reform in
this Parliament haven't uh worked
um but I think it's fair enough if there
is data that they are required to put in
the public domain for them to be asked
about it it is not good enough to say I
just follow the rules I think that if an
MP is then asked about what they've said
they do and then Steve Brown's case you
saw uh some of the figures of the
numbers there as they were he's worked
and uh and and salary he's got then it
is perfectly reasonable to ask how do
you justify that
um and then I think viewers and voters
will uh judge their reaction uh whether
they thought it was uh it was reasonable
um there are people who think the system
isn't working let's listen to the former
SMP leader in Westminster Ian Blackford
there is I think a legitimate debate
about earnings of of MPS I've actually
just gone on to the committee of
standards and public life and I'm sure
all of these things that we will we will
reflect on because I think it is
important that the the public can have
trust and those that they they send to
Parliament and let's make sure that
there's full transparency in this that
people are not abusing the Privileges
that's put in them as as members of
parliament
um now one of the debates that you heard
this morning was a point raised by
Jillian Keegan she said look this is all
skewed by a small number of Mega earners
and it's absolutely true some of the
most famous names in politics are
earning the most and you saw Boris
Johnson and Liz trust giving her views
on global diplomacy uh uh Theresa May of
course uh a regular uh in the leader
tables but but does this skew the figure
of 233 pounds an hour uh do the top
earners mean that that is higher than it
otherwise would be well we did the
calculation not just for the average
which does take into account uh it is
weighted towards those at the top but
the median now in a sense that's the
middle point of the earnings to sort of
to to as it were make sure we we knew
what was going on without
um being over dominated by those at the
top and and there the out the median
earning figure is 173 uh pounds per hour
uh uh pounds per hour for outside
earnings so even if you discount the few
top earners who do an extraordinary sums
often on the global speaking circuit uh
MP still and many many multiples of the
average wage and the minimum wage when
it comes to their outside work awesome
thanks very much indeed
well our Westminster accounts
investigation is the subject of today's
Sky News Daily podcast so scan the QR
code on your screen to listen to it and
you can listen And subscribe for free to
the Sky News Daily wherever you get your
podcasts
now Hollywood's film and TV industry
will effectively shut down in the last
couple of hours actors have officially
joined screenwriters in going on strike
it follows a collapse in talks with
Studios and streaming companies over pay
conditions and concerns over the use of
artificial intelligence Martha Kellner
has the latest
this is the first time in 60 years that
both the writers and the actors in
Hollywood have been on strike at the
same time and it is relatively Uncharted
Territory I was down at a picket line
with writers who have been on strike now
for two months and a huge cheer erupted
as they learned the news that the actors
who bring their words to life would be
joining them on strike because they know
that this makes their bargaining
position with the Production Studios and
the streaming Giants all that much
stronger we've already seen this taking
effect it's not just the film and TV
production that stops almost immediately
it's the bells and whistles around this
industry the things like the premieres
the the pressed on kits the photo shoots
Oppenheimer Premiere in London the Stars
had already walked the red carpet when
they got news that this strike was
happening the likes of Emily Blunt and
Killian Murphy walked away from that
event straight away it's clear that many
many actors are very committed to this
causing in fact I've barely had a
whisper from anyone within the acting
Community who doesn't think that this is
the right course of action and this
campaign has been led by the likes of
Jennifer Lawrence Meryl Streep Mark
Ruffalo they were all signatories to a
letter urging their Union to take a hard
line and this is where We've Ended up
with a dual strike for actors and
writers
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines
and Kevin Spacey claimed he was
flirtatious and romantic with one of his
alleged victims as he started giving
evidence in his sexual assault trial
he's previously denied all 12 charges
against him and faces further
cross-examination today
the funeral of one of the victims of
last month's attacks in Nottingham is
taking place today 19 year old Barnaby
Weber was walking home from a night out
with fellow student Grace O'Malley Kumar
when they were stabbed to death a 31
year old man has been charged with their
murders and will face trial in January
the wildfire that destroyed 17 houses in
Wellington on the outskirts of London
last summer was likely to have started
in a garden a London fire brigade
investigation didn't rule out that the
fire was deliberate but noted that it
struck on the hottest they ever recorded
in the UK
Health authorities in the U.S have
approved a birth control pill for sale
without a prescription for the first
time ever Opel also labeled the mini
pill contains just one hormone and has
been used under prescription since 1973.
people are being forced to pull out
their own teeth at home because they
can't afford all access an NHS dentist
that's according to a new report by the
health select committee which found DIY
extractions have been performed with
pliers in some cases While others have
been forced to make a five hour round
trip to see a professional the committee
recommends updating current contracts
with dentists and launching a public
information campaign to explain how NHS
Dentistry works well the committee's
chair Steve Bryan told me it's a failure
of successive governments
to hear people in such pain and distress
that they're pulling out their teeth is
is a huge worry and the problem's been
compounded by the by the fact that I
think there's very little information
about what people are entitled to when
it comes to NHS dentistry and I think on
our part we're incredibly frustrated
that our predecessor committee 15 years
ago made very clear recommendations in
this area and they still haven't been
followed up so this spans you know the
last government expense the coalition
government and it spans this my own
government
let me just bring you some breaking news
coming into us now almost a thousand
workers at Gatwick Airport including
baggage handlers and check-in staff will
stage eight days of strikes from later
on this month in a dispute overpay
that's according to the unite Union
who's just announced that in the last
few minutes
um so that strikes at Gatwick planned by
the unite Union we'll bring you more
information on that as soon as we get it
in the meantime coming up here on Sky
News break first the new research that
reveals hundreds of children could have
died this year trying to cross the
Mediterranean
[Music]
thank you
independent United Kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child's
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't want to and that is what it is
it's first class profit is this an
example of the welfare state failing
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
now Junior doctors in England are
walking out for a second day today the
government said there'll be no more
negotiations after offering a six
percent salary rise in line with
independent pay review bodies but the
BMA wants 35 percent for millions of
other UK public sector workers do look
set to accept government pay increase
offers including teachers who've now
suspended all their planned strikes well
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
explained how that proposed six and a
half percent rise for teachers will be
funded
what happens in in government budgeting
is if you don't spend it all and very
often you don't spend it all could you
overestimate how quickly you can roll
things out Etc then all that money
usually goes back to the treasury and
what's happened in in this case and the
treasury of work with us to enable us to
do that is they've given us the
flexibility to take those uh anticipated
underspends and to move them into
Teachers Pay so if it's come from an
underspend that's okay for this year but
but what about
future years as well we've looked at
Future years so we've looked at this
year and next year which are the two
years that are left within the spending
review and then of course it gets
Consolidated into the spending review
and that's what happens every year with
everything actually how confident are
you that teachers will accept that given
that it's still below inflation which is
8.7 percent
um I mean it's the unions really that
have got the best judgment on that and
and they they seem to be uh confident uh
that their members will do that but of
course it will have to go to the ballot
but the General Secretary of the trades
Union Congress Paul Novak said there's
little Clarity in other public sectors
as to how those increases are going to
be funded
I know for example uh in health the the
hospital consultants and Specialists
Association at TUC Union is concerned
about you know effectively the salami
slicing of NHS funding Robin Peter to
pay Paul to fund any pay rise and so
they're still calling on the government
to sit around and negotiate so I think
it looks very different in different
parts of the public sector but I think
overall uh I I would say that the Prime
Minister and him accepting those pay
review body Awards wouldn't have
happened if union members hadn't stood
up uh taking that really difficult
decision to vote for strike action and
showed the government that they weren't
prepared to accept getting other uh real
terms papers
well our political correspondent Rappel
is back with me now so what do these pay
Rises mean for public sector workers is
there good news and bad news yeah I
think it's good news and bad news as far
as the government's concerned and as far
as the disputes are concerned as well
obviously for teachers I think you've
got the feeling that Jillian Keegan the
education secretary really felt she had
a good news story to tell this morning
in that the teachers have suspended
their strikes extra money will be going
into schools and they are able to use
some of this underspend within the
department for Education that would
usually go back to the treasury to fund
some of these pay Rises now so I think
her team of cocker who bluntly about how
this has played out the only difficulty
with using though and you've got at this
in your interview with Jillian Keegan
kind of one-off underspends for each
year to fund a permanent pay rise that
obviously stretches off into the future
is that eventually that pay rise has to
be found within your spending plans and
given the spending plans overall the
budget for the spending after 20 24
looks so tight I think it's led many to
wonder whether those spending plans the
government have laid out post 2024 and
the budget for it really is a fiction to
be honest but I guess we'll find out
after the next election whether those
get stuck to in terms of where the
junior doctors are this is where it
starts to get a bit more tricky because
they have already rejected what was put
on the table yesterday they were on
strike at the moment but the Prime
Minister has said that there will be no
more talks so it really looks like they
are in a standoff in a stalemate here
and I think where we're going to end up
at is months more of potential strikes
from the BMA that could harm Rishi sunax
promise to cut waiting lists clearly it
is bad for patients as well but I think
the key here is that for the BMA for the
junior doctors this isn't so much just a
sort of normal annual pay negotiation
for them it's more existential I think
that's why they are asking for more and
that is why we are likely to see more
strikes in the months ahead well yeah
fascinating to see how that one plays
out with the government saying no more
talks yeah Rob thanks very much date
foreign
of that breaking news I brought you just
in the last few minutes almost a
thousand workers at Gatwick Airport are
going to stage eight days of strikes
from later this month in a dispute
overpay so the unite Union is saying
that they include baggage handlers and
check-in staff from four different
companies and there are warnings that
disruption delays and cancellations are
inevitable across the airport so warning
to anyone who's uh planning a trip later
this month to check that out
now the World Health Organization has
formally ruled a common artificial
sweetener used in diet soft drinks are a
possible carcinogen but it won't change
its Health guidance well here's Sky's
Thomas Moore with more
it's called aspartame and if you go into
any Supermarket you're going to see it
in lots of low calorie low sugar foods
and drinks ranging from Diet Coke to
Wrigley's Extra Gum to Muller light
yogurts I mean it is there so it's
really important that we know that it's
safe and one World Health Organization
body has now looked at it and they
categorize something like a thousand
substances so far into the likelihood
that they cause cancer and this is how
they've arrived at the conclusion that
aspartame may possibly cause cancer that
sounds alarming but they look they rank
things right at the top are the things
that definitely cause cancer things like
tobacco and alcohol followed that is
ones that probably cause cancer things
like red meat and then you come down to
the category they were talking about
possible links to cancer aspartame aloe
vera and some other things like that so
it sounds alarming but in fact this
really is based on the the strength of
the scientific evidence and you have to
look at that and if it's possible that
it might be linked to cancer then you'd
think that that evidence is weak they're
not clear at all that there is a risk
now there's another body that's linked
to the United Nations which has tried to
turn all that into real world
um advice that we can use and and
they've concluded that it would be
perfectly acceptable for some for an
adult weighing about 70 kilos to uh to
consume up to 14 cans of of diet fizzy
drink and for a child to consume a 10
year old child weighs about 32 kilograms
that they they would be able to consume
six and a half something like that so
most people will be well below the limit
even if they are breaching that limit
it's still not definite that aspartame
would be definitely causing cancer so I
think you can be reassured unless you're
consuming vast of quantities of
aspartame
Thomas More there now new figures
suggest almost 300 children are believed
to have died or disappeared this year
while attempting to cross the
Mediterranean Sea that's 11 children a
week new research by UNICEF estimates
that more than 11 000 children have made
the dangerous Crossing so far in 2023
the majority were alone Wolverine canals
from UNICEF told us why people make the
dangerous Journey
it is government policies it is
decisions taken in Europe decisions
taken across the countries that are you
know bordering the Mediterranean that
are driving the high number of deaths
because these children have no legal way
no safe way to get on a plane to apply
for family reunification to have their
claim processed and properly assessed
that is why they are turning to these
unsafe routes
much of southern Europe has been baking
in extreme heat this week in Greece the
government has even ordered work to
start between 12 and 5 in the afternoon
in areas where the risk from heat is
very high our energy and climate change
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
reports now from the Greek city of Perez
heat is a public health emergency in
some instances even in a place like
Athens which is a well used to the Heat
this is the port area just outside the
city where we've been speaking to
Holiday makers going off to the islands
and a lot of them have said that they
are being extra cautious they are
heeding the warnings a number of Greek
families have said that they're a little
bit baffled about all the fuss they say
that grease is a very hot place and it's
a society that's already orientated
around taking care of themselves during
the hottest hours but the Greek
authorities are taking no chances
there's been a public health campaign
they're asking people to stay indoors
most public buildings are shut today and
they are saying no food deliveries for
example between 12 and 5 as the heat
builds it's possibly going up to 40
degrees today and it might get even
hotter tomorrow but when you look at the
forecast actually these very high
temperatures high 30s are going to
extend for another 10 days or so so very
little relief for people in Greece and
it's a similar picture across southern
Europe this area of high pressure
trapped over North Africa Spain Portugal
but even into Bulgaria and Kosovo and
we've seen the impact of that already
not just in public health but in
wildfires that have been sparked in
Croatia tourists and residents alike
evacuated that beyond the immediate
impact the emergency issues there's
another thought as well here and that's
about the economic impact on people in
terms of livability in terms of their
abilities to do their job and their
ability to be productive members of
society when it is this hot for this
long those things start to deteriorate
and that's a big problem for governments
that they try to Grapple with this new
reality driven by climate change
Hannah mentioned wildfires that have
started in Croatia well let's just show
you some of the pictures that we've just
had in of the aftermath of those fires
this was the scene in a Coastal Village
about 50 miles from split burnt out cars
and destroyed houses after that Wildfire
swept through and we're hearing there's
been some rainfall that's provided some
respite but evacuation orders were in
place at the time that the fire hit
so a heat wave across parts of Europe
let's take a look at the weather now
closer to home
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well there's a heatwave for southern
Europe but the rather cool and unsettled
conditions here will continue
unseasonably strong winds in the south
over the next few days may bring some
disruption it's a mainly dry start in
the north but Wind and Rain are taking
over more of the South and the rest of
Southern Britain Ireland and Northern
Ireland will see rain through the
morning heavier times
to fly the weather sponsored by Qatar
Airways
coming up here on Sky News breakfast
we'll speak to an expert about the
sweetener commonly found in diet drains
which has been possibly linked to cancer
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's return now to concerns around a
sweetener commonly used in diet soft
drinks and a report from the World
Health Organization has found a possible
link between aspartame and liver cancer
but a panel of experts has said that the
sugar substitute is safe in limited
quantity so let's unpack this a little
bit shall we here with me is registered
dietitian and Senior lecturer at Aston
University Medical School Dr Dwayne
Miller very good morning to you thanks
so much for talking to us so the who has
ruled that aspartame this sweetener used
in in thousands of products is a
possible cause of cancer so how
concerned should we be
well if we look at what possible means
there's a number of things in our
environment which are possible
carcinogens you know aloe vera there are
some compounds that are found in coffee
naturally which have been given the same
label and the who have actually said
that coffee does not increase risk of
cancer there's actually evidence today
reduces it so it's the difference
between what's a hazard and what's a
risk so something may be a problem and
aspartame we don't quite know the
science behind how it could
mechanistically through the biology
course can so we think it's to one of
the compounds it's called methanol as it
breaks down but that also exists in food
we have the data which is over 10 years
old from animal studies which there's
not 100 clear so that's where the
possible comes in and the human data is
unclear because there are big reviews of
people reporting what they eat linking
to risk of cancer but that's not
clear-cut for the liver cancer in
particular it's be a bit hit and miss so
the overall conclusion from the is
possible which is lower than does or
likely
um the the probable and possible it's
the lowest level one of the lower levels
that it may and in the amounts that the
average person consume they're not going
to get anywhere near the equivalent
levels tested animals which is is in the
average adult will be somewhere between
9 and 14 cans of diet soft drinks a day
sorry do go ahead I was going to say the
who also did say that artificial
sweeteners including this party are not
to be widely recommended as a solution
to help people lose weight they can be a
tool to help people reduce their sugar
intake which is part of a healthy diet
but not as a simple switch over from
sugar to sweetness to to solve a health
problem
well yes I was interested when you were
talking about the recommended limits of
what people should should consume of
aspartame and so we've got this warning
but at the same time as you say the
recommended limit for the amount
consumed is unchanged so is that a
confusing message to send out do you
think I think it's how we communicate it
because the possible gives people an
alarm and as a concern which it
shouldn't necessarily do
um what we need to be clear on is this
is to what we call an acceptable daily
intake and if we then quantify that in
cans of drinks but noting that you may
add it to hot drinks as a sweetener have
it in things like medication and sort of
products we use day-to-day things like
toothpaste and things like that you know
the average person will be consuming
well below this so the risk is low and
we also need to be better communicating
risk in life because they're risking
many things that we do
um you know sort of walking across a
road you know daily activities come with
some risk and what they've classified as
being very low risk
um and I think for too long we think
that things don't have an effect on our
bodies and our health and they do but
they're often very very tiny as is being
exemplified by by this report we've seen
today yes and the who owes cancer
research arm has said that there's
limited evidence of a to cancer so
you're surprised that they have put this
out in the public domain
I think because of the amount of media
attention about spartane and we have
lots of interest groups that some people
say they have an effect of it I was
involved in studies when I was working
and doing my PhD where people said they
had negative effects as part-time and we
did a big study funded by the food
standards agency and that showed that
even if we gave him a dummy bar with no
spartamine or a bar with Spider-Man it
had no effect on how they perceive their
symptoms or how their biology changed so
there's people that are concerned about
this sweetener there's also the food
industry which once had these products
available because they give people
choice and I think it's important we
have a clear message which the disarm of
the who have done we just now need to be
better at communicating this suggests
and maybe a hazard but the risk because
of the uncertainty of evidence is likely
very very low and normal consumption is
safe
okay well thanks so much for making that
also clear Professor Kevin mccomway
thanks very much indeed
apologies I've just thanked I've just
given you the wrong name there apologies
for that but thanks very much Dwayne
Miller thanks very much indeed apologies
so it's meant let's move on swiftly
shall we to the sport it's men's
semi-finals day at Wimbledon and uh
let's find out from Jackie what we can
expect from them Jackie should be
another exciting day at Wimbledon yes it
should be men's semis I mean having said
that most people expect Novak Djokovic
will get through to yet another final
here at Wimbledon he's going for eight
five in a row I mean the records just
keep on going for him and if he wins
this one he's up to 24 Grand Slam titles
which is extending his own record and
also uh Mark equaling Margaret Court's
record as well
um he's playing the Alexander today from
Italy very young player 21 who's never
been in a semi-final of Wimbledon before
and very slight but hits the ball with
such ferocity and power you would have
thought Djokovic would have far too much
experience and knowledge of this
situation for cinema today but you you
just never know with these young guys
coming through they are quite fearless
and he has these fans called the karatas
the karate boys the carrot boys who
dresses carrots and follow him around
the world seemingly and because of his
Ginger hair so he'll have a lot of
support on Center Court he's going to
need it against Novak Djokovic in the
the other semi-final we've got Carlos
alcaraz the new world number one who's
who's just 20 and out to make you know a
huge name for himself in terms of
numbers of grand slams he wants to start
building on his record and he is up
against Daniel Medvedev at the Russian
who was banned last year so he's also
out to make his own statement today I
think this one is a little less
clear-cut nevertheless of all of these
players today Djokovic is the most
confident as you would imagine
I don't want to sound arrogant but of
course I do consider myself favorite you
know
you know judging with what the the
results that I had in the in my career
here and in previous
four
occasions of Wimbledon that I won you
know and reaching another semi-final so
I do consider my cell favorite yes
so that's cement semi-finals which is
today and of course even if the
weather's awful it doesn't matter
they've got the roof uh the same for the
women's final tomorrow and that's going
to be interesting because it's going to
be a brand new Champion uh I would say
tunisia's on is the most popular of the
two women in the final she has a lot of
Tunisian fans people loved her last year
when she failed to win the title but it
was a huge comeback for her yesterday in
the semi-final to beat the second seed
from Belarus Arena zavalenka I mean she
was staring down the barrel of defeat
but she managed to turn it round and she
will meet Marquetta Von drusova tomorrow
she is the first unseated player to
reach the women's singles final in the
open era she's check she beat the very
popular Ukrainian Alina spitalina in
straight sets she has many many tattoos
she has had multiple injuries which
she's had to fight back from and she's
only 25 for and she's beaten Jaber twice
already this year it is not a given that
Shabbat wins this one even though it is
her second Wimbledon final
so that's what's happening sw19 let's
catch up on the rest of the sport
this guy new sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
[Applause]
Wimbledon in full bloom one of the most
glorious scenes in all of sport it's a
place this man has got to know well cam
Nori cycled to the Championships and all
the way to the last four last year so
how much does he feel sustainability
time to find out here he is
are you Cam how are you doing very well
thank you good to see you nice to see
you what is it like to be back here
can't complain so nice especially when
the weather's like this yeah so do you
fancy having a little wander around
reliving some memories chat a bit of
climate let's do it let's do it
[Music]
Court 16. talk to me yeah I remember she
was my first ever main draw men's win
here so very special court for me what
did that feel like did it feel like a
major moment for you I think it was one
of those days I was so nervous for the
match so tight because I'd never want to
match here and I just really wanted to
get over the line so I think it was more
of a relief more than like enjoying it
it's all about climate and climate
change when did you first sort of have
exposure to this topic I guess yeah I
actually remember taking a
sustainability class at TCU where I went
to University in the states and one of
the things that stood up for me was I
don't know why but it was in the
Netherlands how many people biked to
work there and I was thinking like for
me why can't I do the same and and
around London when I'm I'm here I'm
biking to practice and definitely it's a
good warm-up good cool down and yeah
growing up and this guy knew Sports
bulletin is brought to you by vitality
Jackie thanks very much indeed do say
well there's lots coming up including
the conservationist Chris Patton tells
us why we're seeing fewer butterflies in
our Gardens and what we can do to help
[Music]
a lot of action going on I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul this
makes a job so fast
so funny
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Stuart Ramsey and I'm Sky's Chief
correspondent well there's a real sense
now that people are beginning to expect
that this whole airlift is coming to an
end and they're really really desperate
we saw snatch words going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover before you
die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
war yeah
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
that whipping crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world they were convinced the
United States would become hooked we're
all right
[Music]
just landed in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network
Jesse in Iraq Iraq Syria but across the
world
[Music]
[Applause]
so so hot
[Music]
thank you
it's like better
[Music]
Fly Emirates fly better
foreign
ERS are calling on the public to help
discover the impact of extreme weather
on British butterflies the last 12
months have seen record temperatures
heat waves and drought all of which have
affected plants that caterpillars
normally feed on we'll enjoyed Now by
Wildlife expert Chris Packham who's also
vice president of the charity butterfly
conservation so a very good morning to
you so you're calling on people to get
involved in the big butterfly count
aren't you so explain what that is and
and how people can help
well the big battle account is a great
piece of Citizen science he's been
running for a number of years now and we
asked people to go out and spend 15
minutes of their time in one spot
counting the number of a small group of
butterflies those which are widely
spread over the UK and easy to identify
so you'd have to be an expert to take
part in this ideal from three to 103 a
year uh ages and you can do it with your
family of course and the other thing to
say is that you don't have to be in the
countryside we would light your records
from your garden or your suburban area
your Supermarket car park or your school
ground and it runs up until the 6th of
August now the benefit of looking at
this is that we get large numbers of
people taking part so last year nearly a
hundred thousand data sets were sent in
and that means we can get a snapshot of
these animals populations at that point
in time and compare it over previous
years the the account has been going for
a number of years now and we've seen
quite significant changes in the
populations and the distributions of
these insects they're very apparent
they're easy to spot they're part of our
culture we love them we love looking at
them it's good for our mental health
actually to zone out for 15 minutes and
focus just on nature so it's a
win-win-win situation it's a win for our
mental health it's a win for getting
together to focus on nature and connect
with it more in our communities and your
data will be very valuable to us when it
comes to understanding how climate is
having an impact on their populations
well yes and what have you learned today
to what extent are butterfly populations
depleted by our changing weather
well not just our changing weather but
climate habitat fragmentation overuse of
pesticides what I can tell you very
sadly is that in recent years we've seen
80 percent of our butterfly species in
quite significant Decline and and that's
obviously quite worrying because these
insects are our good indicator to wider
natural Community Health obviously their
caterpillars are an important food stuff
all of our breeding birds in the spring
when it comes to moths the bats that we
uh have flying around our fish should be
feeding on those at night so by focusing
on these insects which we see plenty of
and and part of our community we learn a
lot more about that that how the health
of that Community now in the last couple
of years we've had some quite
significant weather events which have
impacted negatively upon them cast your
mind back to the drought last year all
of the caterpillars food plants would
have withered and as a consequence of
that we saw far fewer of the springtime
butterflies this this year that we've
predicted now in the last couple of
weeks we've seen quite a few of our
summer species emerging in good numbers
but we're in the middle of a drought now
well I know I've got my Broly up because
it's raining for the first time in weeks
down here in the south of England but
everything is very very dry so these
sorts of cold wet swings dry droughts
throughout the course of the summer are
certainly having an impact on their
populations and unless we understand it
then we can't implement the conservation
measures which we've had tried and
tested they work broadly enough and
rapidly enough to to conserve these
creatures and that's what we're about of
course well yes and give us an idea of
what those conservation measures look
like
well we've reintroduced species of
butterflies that have actually become
extinct in the UK rather famously we
lost the large Blue a downland species
and that was reintroduced with animals
that were brought from overseas we've
also reintroduced other species by
moving them around from one part of the
UK to another I mentioned habitat
fragmentation that means that
populations become fragmented and
disconnected so if one of them becomes
locally extinct we now have the
capability of obviously moving them from
one place to another but frankly there's
no point in moving them unless you've
got decent habitat there so habitat
restoration is very much at the core of
what we need to do and that sort of
building from the literally from the
ground up is about having the right
soils it's about having the right plants
growing there many of their larval
stages of course are are are
herbivorous they're feeding on those
plants you've got to get the plants in
place first then you can reintroduce the
the butterflies um although naturally
recolonize as well of course and then
it's about connectivity hedgerows are
really important that we maintain those
in good house so that these creatures
can move from one part of our landscape
to another so there are a number of
things that we can do but they do work
but we've just got to to roll them out
more quickly and more broadly to address
these quite significant declines okay
well Chris Pack and really interesting
to hear about this year's big butterfly
count and I'm sure everyone's heard your
message loud and clear and we'll be off
to their local open area or their Garden
to take a look and start counting Chris
Pack and thanks very much indeed
thank you very much indeed
quick look at the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well there's a heatwave for southern
Europe but the rather cool and unsettled
conditions here will continue
unseasonably strong winds in the south
over the next few days may bring some
disruption and it's a mainly dry start
in the north but Wind and Rain are
taking over more of the South
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
that's it for today but uh plenty more
coming up on Sky News in just a moment
all the top stories at the top of the
hour don't go away
[Music]